The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the fleshlight,
and if you go to Joe Rogan.net,
click on the link for the flashlight.
You will get 15 percent off the number
one sex toy for men.
Oh yeah.
Is that me?
That's me in the background and my own
computer.
The fuck is wrong with me after all
these months of doing this.
Still can't get it right.
I shut the phone off though.
I fucking swear to God.
I did.
Bert crashes in the House bitches
experience the machine crisis spreading
like herpes all across America.
Dude,
you're spreading.
You're a pilot and you're affected and
you're taking me everywhere with him.
No,
no,
no.
It's impossible to make someone famous
if they're not talented.
You are extremely talented and hilarious
and that's why you're becoming huge.
But I'm fucking hearing you everywhere.
I got a clip that opie and anthony sent
me.
Were they a thing?
But think about where that started from.
It started for me,
the one that had the couch here.
We're telling you how to crazy.
Drove out.
Oop.
And I was telling you,
they're great guys and you're like,
I'm scared of doing their show.
I had this crazy dream when you go on
Opiod,
Anthony,
and you can see opiod,
like looking at his computer and he's
like,
sweet,
you dream about me.
Tell me about your dreams.
And I was like,
God,
God.
But it was literally in this show is.
So I was telling Brian,
I sang it the,
at the braves game yesterday,
uh,
did the seventh inning stretch.
And I sit up on the dugout.
Nice thing last year,
right after the first season of birth.
Concrete.
And no one saying the national,
no,
the stretch take me out to the ballgame.
So I get up on the thing black blasts
you.
When I did at my kids were there and my
wife was their whole families there.
And I got up and everyone just looked at
me like,
who the fuck's this guy?
Last night,
yesterday when I did it,
the whole side knew who I was.
And I'm telling you,
so many people were yelling the machine.
So fucking bizarre.
Right?
You're talking about every show.
I do every show,
I do.
Not only do people give me joints and
go,
this is a present for the machine.
Some chick gave me three.
Vicodin was like,
I thought the machine would like these.
I was like,
are you kidding me?
Last night the most buckled down,
uh,
people in the front row is a guy and a
girl just really like Range Rover
buckhead type of people,
you know.
And she says,
um,
I said something and she goes,
someone yells,
let machine.
And I said,
I'll tell that story.
And she said,
powerful Bert Kreischer
talk to you on the phone.
I just talked to him
and you had just said something like,
you fucking kidding me.
Like,
it's bizarre because you cannot put a
finger on who is,
who is a fan of the podcast,
you know,
like it just doesn't make sense.
Who is or who is it that has some old
lady the airport telling me she loves
it.
So many people listen to this guy who
traveled to handle any.
My boss is like,
I just want to catch you before you hop
on the Rogan podcast.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I was like,
how many of you listened to.
It's insane.
I was telling you,
and I will always say this,
the last thing I'll say about this
podcast before we talked about regular
shit is I had to call you from New York
when I was coming home from letterman
because when I sat down in a letterman
dressing room,
all the stories,
they were like,
can you tell this time?
Remember the story you told them?
Rogan's podcast can tell that.
Okay,
there are six stories I read before we
about to go on letterman that are all
pulled from literally pulled from this
podcast and I went,
Holy Shit.
And I literally,
I called my wife that morning and it was
a surreal moment after you do Letterman,
I'm driving to the airport and I'm
telling her,
I go,
it's all fucking Rogan.
Like it's,
you know,
that podcast is just such.
It's such a different thing than is out
in media.
And she was like,
you need to call him right fucking now.
Like I'm not calling joe to tell him
thank you.
She goes,
don't get that.
Is your that is your ego talking.
You just fucking call him and thank him,
and I was like,
fuck it.
I was hungover,
done check.
Talk to him like that.
You got to do podcasts and started to
institute the rape joke and a hard fuck
session just to get that out of her
system.
Her let her know what the fuck did you
just tell me to do?
Oh,
it's my ego,
my ego.
Just take that.
You're going to inoculate her with some
sperm.
Clear her of all that nonsense,
telling you what to do.
Dude,
that was the nicest thing ever.
You know you.
You're such a thoughtful guy and you're
such a friendly guy and a happy guy and
that's why all these good things are
happening to you,
man.
But there's very few people would have
called and left such a nice little email
like that.
It was very heartwarming,
man.
You're a cool motherfucker was like I
said,
there's no way it wouldn't have helped
you if you weren't already hilarious.
It's just we,
you know,
people found out about you,
but it's you.
It's not us.
Excellent.
It's been been trying to work that tell
a story.
Machine age,
ages so hard.
It's not,
it's not like,
dude,
that's your.
Get her done.
Don't even have to tell the story,
man.
You're the fucking machine,
you know,
just inform them that you're the machine
now.
Just let them know and then that's your.
Get her done because I'm the machine.
Oh,
Jean shirts yet?
No,
no.
Uh,
those,
those guys that are making that
documentary or making machine shirts.
Uh,
I am the machine washing.
Yeah.
You heard about this documentary,
they're trying to follow him around for
a month and raising money or I send you
a tweet and what is the,
what is it would explain it.
So there's A.
Oh shit.
I should've had it fucking.
Yeah.
Let me find the tweet.
Go to kickstarter.com.
Ask Bert.
Oh,
I bet.
I'm sure I did send it to you that.
Hold on a second.
It's on kickstarter.com
and see twitter's deal.
But deletes your messages.
If you leave them on there too long,
you don't.
They don't keep them meat,
which means someone's probably reading
your shit.
So the oldest one I got from you is,
it's something about you,
uh,
doing that,
a thing that you had to do in Florida?
Yeah.
Well,
not anymore.
The uh,
so,
so the
first time we did this,
the first time I did this podcast with
this guy,
these two editors in this place called
big boss isn't here the production
company.
We're listening to it and you were like,
you should do a show,
you should write a book called exit
strategies because all the crazy shit
that happens on stage to me.
So and I.
and because of that I've just welcomed
it and it's gotten even fucking crazier.
Like the Thursday night on stage I had
three black guys onstage and we were
trying to write a racist white joke,
like a joke that would hurt white
people's feelings because I've never
heard one and I've never heard a joke.
Like what do you call a white guy
standing in front of a judge?
The lawyer I guess like there's no like
great racist joke.
So we were trying to write one and then
these guys.
And I came to the opinion that only
white couples have a hard time getting
pregnant.
Like that's the big,
that's our tragedy.
But you never hear like,
oh,
licorice and right.
Were having a hard time conceiving so he
can.
They were like,
we don't know.
One black couple has ever had a hard
time because even so we tried to write a
hurtful white joke,
but we just couldn't find the right
rhythm anyway.
So all these women who have already done
it by now,
no.
The closest we could find were Polish
jokes.
That's it.
Yeah.
Polish jokes are effective,
but you have to be Polish.
That's gonna suck.
If you're the one race,
that's automatically considered to be
kind of a knucklehead race.
Yeah.
How rude.
Well,
you know how the Polish people got that
right?
It was probably because they were
illegal immigrants,
right?
Nope.
What it was doing.
The Germans rolled through Poland,
the Polish,
we're really proud and they brought in
and tanks and the police came up and
started hitting the tanks with sticks.
And the Germans are like,
are you fucking kidding me?
Just and killed.
We just killed them off and they're
like,
these guys are fucking fighting with
sticks.
But they were proud they were defending
their country.
So then that started the rolling of
Polish jokes.
Even put ski came along in the eighties.
Who's uh,
you know,
I haven't put.
Ski was a fucking very famous pro
wrestler.
Polish power.
I haven't put ski.
It was a little short guy,
but he was fucking super yolked.
Seriously?
Yeah.
Polish power.
I haven't put ski.
Yeah,
it was a tank.
No,
I don't.
Anyway,
so.
No,
I don't remember this.
no,
no.
That's how Polish no racist joke for
wiping.
Anyway.
Yeah.
So that's what we were doing on stage
and then we end up doing a shot of
Tequila and then we're all,
we all get off and then with these guys
heard me on this podcast and said,
man,
your shit wild.
So wild on the road and all these stores
were crazy.
Let's see if we can try to capture
lightning in a bottle,
will follow you for a month on the road
and just document it and see if we can
find some good stories that happened.
Should should've fucking fuck came this
weekend.
It was chaos this weekend.
But,
but so then they,
they made this proposal,
put it on kickstarter.
It's on kickstarter.
Brian,
can you find it?
If you just type in kickstarter and then
go and then in the search type and burt
you'll find it and every dollar you
donate you get something back.
Whether it's a credit in the movie,
like a thank you in the movie.
A personal workout session in my man
cave.
Like a tee shirt.
He's got a man cave without alligator
hands and everything for the whole
fucking man cave.
You got a man cave in your house?
Oh,
it's the best thing that's ever happened
to life.
Wow.
Oh,
remember you when you show me your,
your,
uh,
garage Mahal.
The Gym.
Yeah.
And I was like,
Oh,
I think I'm getting a man.
Man-Cave I gotta fuck it,
man cave.
So after that you got out.
Did you make it yourself?
Diy Networks?
Tony started Uzzah.
Jason Cameron came to my house,
a man cave.
My Shit.
Wow.
The best thing that has ever happened in
my life.
When does it air?
It's already here.
It's already here,
but if you have ever had something so
positive happening in your life and like
a week that you're like,
I'm totally dying,
I'm going to die in St Louis.
No,
I'm going to die before that happens.
I'll never get to see the.
Because it was so cool.
I was so excited for it.
So yeah,
but.
So what exactly did they do?
The A to 60.
Someone's going to come rob me,
but to 60.
Don't give out your address.
Flat screen.
Three d TV's a keg rater,
a wine refrigerator,
a thousand cigar humidor.
All 200 year old reclaimed lumber on the
inside from a barn in Indiana.
They,
uh,
a desk in there as a back of a corvette.
It's kind of cheesy,
but it looks cool,
like,
you know,
and they fucking polished.
Then they,
then they sealed up the one part,
the old entrance.
It was a door and they open up a wall to
the backyard and put in these humongous,
a fucking open like French doors.
10 foot French doors that open up to the
backyard,
put fill.
The whole backyard was 1700 square feet
of pavers.
Gave me a fire pit.
I mean you're just supposed to make the
man cave.
And they were like and Tony's Goossen
and Jason and I got along and they're
like,
fuck it.
Let's call out.
It's like a hundred grand.
They dropped on this fucking mannequin.
It makes my shit.
It's like when you see me,
like when you see me naked,
I've outgrown my Dick,
my Dick.
Smaller than my waist.
More.
They should be all my body.
That's what my house looks like compared
to my man cave.
A big guy with a little tiny dick.
It's wow.
That's fucking awesome.
Just increased the value of your house.
Probably we won't be able to for that
shit.
Yeah.
No,
but it's the best thing that we only
hang out with Medicaid,
but I'm going to go inside anymore.
Do you have to pay more taxes when your
house is worth more?
Even if you already own it?
Yeah,
I think so.
That's what they told us.
They were like,
is that true?
Is that like people are people at old
houses?
I thought as if he's getting it
appraised or if he sold it.
I didn't know if it will.
If you just added to it.
Finances were exactly.
Men Boys,
Lego my thing.
He just call Santa Claus with free hug
coupon cat pictures and heard those guys
like cats with Brian.
Brian.
He's just talking about 10 different
things.
Oh,
is crazy.
I go,
do you have add?
And he goes,
yeah,
maybe.
Maybe,
maybe it doesn't matter.
I'm highest fucking shit right now.
Shit.
We did a podcast this morning with a
grower and he was with a grower.
Yeah.
So let's do some dangerous characters.
Those growers to grow marijuana.
It's not easy.
I tried in New York.
Did you?
Yup.
I grew up plant on my,
on my fire escape,
and I was just like,
I was just water it and I'll get some
sun.
It will be perfect.
And then so then growing.
It's one thing.
Then you got to drive the shit out.
Like you've got to drive much.
How big did it get about the.
About the size of my hand.
Whoa.
The buds.
No,
no,
no.
You know,
let's just ballpark it and just say it
was marijuana.
I'm not even sure what I grew up.
I definitely smoked it and I definitely
grew it and I dried it and we got high,
but I don't know,
it didn't look like the kind of weed you
buy.
So it was just shit weed.
You fucked up really bad read.
Well I think it's like anything else.
You got to really look into it.
You know,
I have a good friend who is a
professional grower and has been forever
and went to jail time.
Mccormick has been on the podcast before
todd's been.
He's a,
he's a legit grower though.
You know what I mean?
I mean he grows for,
you know,
to Spencer's.
It's so difficult.
Right.
It's like I felt you just plant a seed.
You gotta Let.
Well you can.
I mean it does.
It's.
It is wild.
Yeah.
But it can grow on its own.
But they would.
This was when I was working at Barnes
and noble when we grew it,
so I brought up with good on the
basement,
read books on marijuana growing and you
have to like put it in,
you have to put it in.
I'm like a moist towelettes in the
refrigerator and let the stems like let
us start seeding and then plant it like
you can't just bury it.
No,
because people throwing the fucking weed
out the window when they were being
chased by cops and the grows because of
the seeds take into the side of the road
grows if there's definitely a pop liquid
or my parents stopped because there are
tons of seeds under.
There are so many factors.
You have to have parasites.
We got parasites.
It's like little little bugs one time
and they just killed our whole crop.
Something in our house.
Yeah,
and there's a lot of shit you have to
worry about growing,
but yeah,
that also then you have the miracle bugs
that just.
It's not to me,
it's not like in this,
in this day and age,
it's like the only way I would do it,
the only for,
the only reason was because like they
say that about mushrooms as well,
that when you grow them that you develop
a relationship with them,
like they connect with you because
you're nurturing them and taking care of
them and then when you actually finally
eat it,
it gives you even more of a high real.
It's almost.
Yeah,
because it's almost like they say like
there's a difference between going
hunting and buying a steak at the
grocery store.
There's a whole process that skipped
when you buy the steak at the grocery
store,
so you just become this sort of non
thankful gelatinous fucking Slob who
just say you don't have to be able to
get that thing.
That thing is already provided for you.
Were you the person talking about eating
only like eating only like deers and
like running me,
it means so much sense.
I was on a plane piss drunk listening to
that and I was like,
fuck that.
I was my own personal theory
thing that things are difficult to
catch.
I probably way better for you.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Because you got to be clever to catch
them.
You got to be clever to catch a deer.
You're going to be clever to catch a
fish,
you know?
That's why they're really good for you.
There is so filled with nutrients in
there.
They know that that's why they're
running like crazy.
The reason why they're running like fast
and cows are just kind of wandering in
excuse cows or retards and are supposed
to take them out and you know,
deer are two.
They're just faster.
Maybe if that that's suppose to be a
challenge because you're not supposed to
eat it though.
Kind of like a.
like a snake has crazy colors and it to
warn you off.
If it had thumbs you,
it would be eating you.
That's all.
You have to realize.
I've had snake snake,
I bet to make red rattlesnake
rattlesnake every.
I had.
I had one when we did the extra we did.
They had a smorgasbord of,
of crazy animals like lion and tiger,
and it was just fucking.
Oh,
I see
growing your own shit,
man.
I think there's something to that.
I think there's something to that
because if you talk to a guy that's,
you know,
like that's gone hunting and they'll
talk to you about eating the food that
you caught yourself,
whether it's a fucking rattlesnake or
this whole shows on it about where they
go.
And you know,
when people go and sustain themselves
off the land,
like there was that guy that was on your
network.
Um,
but wild within Don wildman did the
wildest thing.
I don't remember his name.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Is that still going on?
Is that they cancel it?
No,
but I want that dog that he went hunting
boars with.
That's the fucking dog.
Oh,
the dogs that logged they show is this
show was really hardcore and they,
those dogs attack people though this dog
hits attack people less than those dogs.
Are you shitting my most pits or not?
Their dog aggressive number.
Then there are people,
aggressive dreams.
Are they.
Because my dog,
I used to have a pit that was a Hawaiian
boar hunting.
I want the Doggos Argentinos.
Yeah,
those are the dangerous ones.
Those are those ones that bite people
don't like the size of a great Dane,
but the body of a pit,
huge pit bulls is what they are and they
use them for hunting bores.
They hold onto the board and then this
guy comes along on fucking the travel
channel and stabs him to death with a
knife.
That's how they killed the bore.
They grab it and then you come along and
slice it's fucking throat right there.
I mean it is down and gritty.
And I watched that show and I was like,
wow,
what a show.
This is like this show.
I mean we used to have a show.
It's a fucking good God damn show.
Why did they cancel it?
You know,
it's the same shit that happens with
everything good.
What it is,
it's too much right up front for
everyone.
So what they'll do now,
I guarantee you tlcl do a show called
boar hunting and that'll be the show.
That's how these,
like I did what I did when we did birth
conquer,
we went a cafetiere scrabbling where you
put your hand on.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
If I catch a fish called noodling,
noodling catfish,
grappling dog in whatever redneck plays
you're in,
they have a different name for it.
Grappling,
grappling,
Eman Gary a shit.
Fuck.
Yeah,
because you're doing it with rednecks.
Who you never think they felt the whole
plant through.
The guys like Greg.
He goes,
he's go on and shelby,
I will hand back in Uganda and Rwanda
and you're going to nibble now when you
feel a nipple,
you better hold on that day as a and not
a alligator snapping turtle or a beaver.
I was like,
there's a fucking.
There could be an alligator in there.
Like there could be.
I was like,
how can we get something other than my
fucking hand in there?
Something that we don't want.
I want my hand and then they just like,
don't be a pussy boy.
Oh my God,
man.
Let me tell you something.
When that fish bites on God,
you feel like a fucking warrior.
Like,
oh cause it,
cause it's,
it's,
it's go time,
like I'm waving at you,
just,
it's like Flash Gordon,
you got your hand in a hole and you're
and you're underwater and you're waving
your arm and back in a hole and you can
hear the thump.
It thumps when it starts rolling and
you're like,
and you can hear it under water,
right?
Because it took fucking 50 pound catfish
and then all of a sudden he goes,
you won't feel to nibble.
I was like,
yeah,
fuck a car door slamming on my hand,
just Bam.
And I pull a 50 pound kapish out of a 20
pound hole.
It's like pulling a kindergarten round,
a whole just like,
what the fuck is it?
It's massive.
And then I panicked.
I just dropped it.
I go get him.
Then they started,
they go,
what the fuck is you doing?
Get up on it.
And I was like,
I have no fucking idea to get.
Um.
So did you still have it?
It was flipping around.
It was,
there were three girls there because
it's,
the whole pitch was that they do it with
girls and the girls definitely do it.
The girls definitely catch catfish,
but the dudes like set it up,
you can totally tell the dudes are
setting it up and uh,
and then the catfish whereby a boat
dock,
a ramp where a boat goes in and so the
catfish,
I throw it and it became a boise and it
went over to the dock and he started
swimming up the boat,
ramp up the boat ramp.
So I just run and just jumped all over
you.
A fumble lands on the catfish and just
like all my body weight grabbed it.
And then a lot of them have spines to be
really careful.
I wish I had thought that whole thing
through and stab,
you know.
No,
I was totally fine.
Oh my God.
And I've been stabbed by campus,
but if you see their spines,
yeah,
I used to fish a lot when I was a kid.
Really uncertain cat fish when you catch
them,
when you pick them up,
man,
get stabbed by their dorsal fins.
Know there's pictures of it online if
you want to see how big the catfish was.
It was,
it was monster and I just dove on it and
then,
and then,
then I was like,
I was a fucking liberal because liberal
bent again because they were like,
I was.
I was like,
you know,
I'm all excited.
I'm jazz,
I'm talking to the other redneck.
And I'm like,
Oh man,
that was fucking intense.
Like,
that's so crazy.
Like what fucking makes her bite my what
makes it bite my hand?
And he goes,
well she protecting her babies and I was
like,
what?
He's like,
there's babies in that hole.
That's why she's protecting her babies.
And I went,
I just pulled a fucking mom away from
her kids and I started thinking like,
like what if someone just lifted my wife
away from my children and they were just
sitting in a hole going,
does anyone know how to make a grilled
cheese?
Like just fucking panicking.
You're a Dick Burke.
So then so then I get down,
I get down on the thing and I were
trying to run water through it skills.
I'm just pushing it back and forth like
I'm fucking just so that's how you keep
it alive,
keep it alive,
and then I just let it go and he just
went and he goes,
what the fuck did you do?
I was like,
she got away.
I didn't mean for it to happen.
He was like,
Oh,
you lied.
You have fucking told her that.
I was like,
I can't let.
I can't let that happen.
I'm jumping off a fucking God damn
bridge.
Extra catfish.
Went back there and ate dollars.
Kids so stressed out.
We ended up catching for the entire
days.
We ended up back there.
A bunch of them just slaughtered their
babies and now there's a catfish,
a show the show.
So that was what my whole point of
saying that is that that's how that
works is that you'll,
you'll,
they'll see something really good like
that guy and then I guarantee you that I
take that back.
There is a fucking show.
It's called Hoggin.
I just heard about this.
There was a show called hog and it's all
about a feral hogs and I could tell you
in two seconds because the production
company that I was at birth,
the conquerors does birth,
conquer,
produces hoggin.
Well,
we don't realize
is out here in the city.
We don't realize out here with the white
man what the,
what the real fucking problem is with
the white man.
Was that a real.
What I mean with the,
uh,
the urban man as I should have said,
city,
urban,
using the correct term.
The person living in a city,
urban,
white,
urbanized is white people.
Fuck organs.
Our special is so fucking good.
Okay,
let's start.
Sorry,
you threw me completely off track.
Let's talk about urbanites.
Excellent.
Um,
what was I saying?
Well,
we don't understand.
Oh,
that how big of a fucking problem.
Wild hogs are wild hogs to people that
live in rural areas.
There are fucking huge problem,
man,
because there's not a lot of people
chasing after him.
So they're constantly breeding and
they're smart as fuck.
And they hide from people and they
destroy entire farms.
They just fuck up crops.
They just come in and there's not shit
you can do about them,
so you can hunt them all year round.
There's no bag limit on them because at
this point they are literally an
infestation like we're lucky we don't
live there.
Could you imagine if you went outside
and you're fucking backyard and there's
wild pigs,
big ones.
Fucking tusks.
Hundreds of pounds took out the king on
game of thrones.
Was a fucking pig sending.
Well Watch the game was going to hog
hunting and they got them to drunk in
the hall.
Gordon and Toro to stomach.
So he died.
Yeah.
Those fucking things are obese.
I had a friend,
James App,
Thorpe,
who used to hunt them and I don't know
why you can't just shoot them with a
bone arrow or something and get close to
them.
Oh really?
The dogs find them down.
The
dog's grabbed them and bite them and
hold them down.
My,
my pit that I to have frank,
he was a hog hunting dog from Hawaii.
He was so crazy.
Craziest dog I've ever had.
Really?
And yeah,
he was a great dog with people,
but he was so animal aggressive,
like a never seen anything like this and
killed two of my cats.
He just,
he was always like,
cats would fuck with him.
He'd be fine with them and then they
would piss in the corner or something.
He would just decide,
all right,
I'm going to kill one of your fucking
cats.
It would just go kill one.
It was,
it was no joke.
My.
He would only do it.
I don't mean to be laughing,
but it's just.
He would only do it when I wasn't
around.
That's the crazy thing in front of Eddie
Bravo and once in front of my wife.
That's what burt,
you keep on saying you went to this
crazy dog that's.
You don't want those dogs,
Bro.
Trust me.
You might want to talk to him and just
get a nice dog wars in my house.
I've had dogs killed dogs,
but you don't.
Yeah.
You don't know what that's like.
Do you come home and one of your female
pitts has killed the other female pit or
killed her dead in your living room?
And I got to clean up the blood.
Yeah,
dude,
he's not a joke.
The those animals or they look cool
because you and I are both 15 year old
boys at heart,
so like fucking look at that fucking
animal on that.
Dude,
I want to have that.
They're very dangerous and people get on
me all the time because I say this shit.
I see this as a guy owned pits for 10
years.
I still love pits.
I think they're amazing dogs.
They're so fucking intelligent because
the cruel nature of dog fighting.
Because the way it's set up,
they only allowed the purest of the
bloodline to survive.
They kill off the ones that quit to kill
off the ones that don't want to fight to
kill off the ones that don't show
absolute courage and no human
aggression.
They're not supposed to ever be
aggressive to humans.
The only attack dogs.
And that's way that way men can get in
there and separate the dogs as they're
fighting.
So what you develop is this super loyal,
loving wants to please you has this
incredible drive like no other dog.
The driver pitbulls insane.
They will jump up and hold onto a tire
with their jaw for an hour.
Just hang there.
Their drive is so different than any
other dog,
and until you've appreciated that you,
you really,
you don't.
You don't know why people love those
dogs so much,
but they're dangerous fact.
They're dangerous with dogs.
They're dangerous with little people.
They're dangerous with old people.
My dog did not like old people,
so one of my biggest fears was that old
people would come by my fence and he'd
go,
it wasn't like,
you know,
hey,
better back the fuck away from the
fence.
It's like,
I've got this.
I got this.
It was like his prey drive sense that
this person was no longer a person
anymore.
There was so weak and so old that his
killer instinct,
like that's what you go after.
That's what a killer animal goes after.
They see a weakness like hyenas.
You can raise hyenas as a pet,
but if you show any signs of weakness,
like if you limp in front of a Hyena,
you better hope that fucking has got a
muzzle on or you better hope that things
got a muzzle on because it won't be able
to protect it.
We're one people to help itself.
It won't be able to help itself even
though you've raised it your whole life.
If a hygienist sees you limping the lock
on you with those fucking crazy eyes and
the strongest snapping jaws known to
mankind in the mammal world at least,
and they just take a big chunk out of
your asshole.
That's your pet hyena that you want to
do.
You want this cooler,
cool.
pound beast,
but you fucked up and went and played
tennis and you gotTa Limp and you came
home with me and it just eats you.
It would be so.
You need that.
Start watching dogs.
One one to really know about animals.
I've been researching dogs for the
better part of every single weekend.
I'm on the road.
All I do,
my pal Bryan County,
and I talk about this all the time
because we've all,
we've had pit bulls or whole life and
I've called Brian in the middle of dog
fights and his dogs fighting one of his
dogs.
It's just his,
his,
his ex girlfriend's dog was this amazing
dog,
was also this crazy pit bull that was
constantly getting in fights.
They get in fights,
man.
Period.
I don't give a fuck what anybody says.
It's very hard to stop that shit and
it's not just the bureau,
it's not just the boys,
the girls,
the girl dogs are hyper aggressive.
There
were your parents.
Were your parents like you buy them as
puppies?
Two of them,
what will.
One of them is a puppy and two of them I
rescued two of them you rescue and they
were both very different,
but both very fucked up.
One of them was a full,
full grown two year old female and she
had mange all over her body and I saw
her.
I found her friend.
A friend found her and then I came to
he.
They called me and said,
we found this dog,
you know,
are you still interested in adopting a
dog?
And I saw her and she was just.
She had the sweetness eyes and covered
in mange and I was like,
oh my God,
I have to save this dog.
It was just like,
this dog was like,
I don't know what to do.
Hey,
I'm just a nice dog.
I'm a sweetheart.
And she was the sweetest dog.
She was.
So.
Except if she thought you were trying to
take too much attention from me or
accept.
Really?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Any dog she would fucking snap them and
bite them in the face and fucking
grabbed.
It was a weird thing,
man.
They have this incredible desire for
human attention and approval.
All right.
Then we'll just get a friendly dog.
Man.
I want.
Here's what I want.
I want the other.
I was telling you guys,
this is when we walked in for the
morning or the night.
My doorbell rang in the middle of the
night.
I'm home.
The one night I'm home in the,
in the week the doorbell rings.
Both girls are in bed with me and lands
in the girls room and I start panicking
thinking this is how it goes down.
That ring the doorbell.
You go to the door,
you turn off the alarm,
you opened the door.
That's what a soccer would do.
Not Me because I'm fucking.
Because I'm already five steps ahead of
them.
So I take the girls in the,
in the bedroom with Leanne,
I go everyone out the fucking window.
I'm going to stop whatever is happening,
but you guys out the window out the back
door,
go to the corner of Laurel Canyon and
uh,
this is before even go to the door
before
I go to the fucking door because I'm
like four in the morning.
Get a gun,
a doorbell for we,
we haven't gotten.
We haven't gotten the doorbell.
Four in the morning.
What the fuck?
There's no,
no good is coming out of that.
There's nothing good.
No one's like,
hey,
I broke down.
We live in a fucking busy intersection
like we're a block away.
So I just fuck in.
I start panicking.
Leanne,
as I'm in talking to Leanne,
I hear the doorbell go again and I'm
like,
uh,
now I'm like,
you will you ever get like,
where your asshole just goes wide,
like wide open like hall,
and you're like,
oh fuck.
And I go,
do you hear it?
And she goes,
it's the girls music,
the girls music's playing.
That's not the doorbell is the music.
So I'm like,
okay.
So it wasn't the fucking doorbell,
but then I thought to myself,
so I'm not crazy.
So then I'm like,
fuck it.
I want a beast in my house that is
willing to give its life for my family.
I want somebody that is going to.
I got an alarm system and I got a gun.
No,
no,
no.
That's a good idea to have a dog.
I just don't recommend pitbulls.
I don't need to impress a canary in
recommending those,
those,
those dogs that,
those are the dogs that uh,
that actor killed a man who,
who's the guy who was in pulp fiction?
The black dude with a shaved head.
What the fuck's his name?
Names.
Yeah,
thing.
Graham's had a let's find.
Let's find the article so we know.
Yeah,
my dogs the best guard dog.
So if he starts barking,
that means there's somebody around my
house and it's all in its brief because
there's a Pekinese.
It was a,
uh,
that's what it was bred for as an alarm
system dog.
Yeah.
Is this going to alarm dogs?
Kill worker at ving?
Rhames home or a 40 year old man was
mauled to death by as many as four dogs
at the home of ving rhames before,
before Joe's dogs went crazy and went
crazy.
He used to have me babysit his dogs when
he was out of town,
so I'd bring my girlfriend at the time
and we'd go there to feed the dog.
And one time she's like feeding the dog
and the dog like bitter in the hand.
But it was kind of like a,
was that a playful bite or fight?
But I was so scared.
Every time I would go to his house
because of that,
you can tell some dogs you just can't
trust.
That's why I'm surprised that little guy
in that TV show pit boss.
I'm surprised I didn't even alive shop
was hanging out with lions.
Yeah,
I mean there's dogs are the size of him.
and he's like,
no,
they're just good.
They can take an Rv.
He rescued a dog that was all fucked up
and beat up from dogfights the other day
in an alley and it was just him and his
dog that had open wounds that just got
done with a fucking.
They've staged that show.
There's so much stage.
At one time they were like,
they were like good that he showed up
and there was a pit bull in a dumpster
and I was like,
you know that some pa was like,
how close are they?
Why don't you have to put a pebble in
the dumpster?
Shows.
Definitely fake like 90 percent of that
90 percent of all those fucking show.
I can't even sit through half of them
anymore.
When you watch the setup,
like you're like,
well like hulk Hogan walks in and he's
like,
well my agent just called,
looks like we're going into the Bermuda
this weekend.
And they're like,
but I have these friends.
I'm like,
fucking seriously.
I watched,
I watched the,
uh,
the new.
What's uh,
what's the girl had the new Paris Hilton
one on its own.
Yeah.
What's owns that?
Oprah's Oprah's network.
Has a Paris Hilton Shell for real.
Paris Hilton's got to say that to him.
Paris whole gun.
Show this to me.
You're going to be doing.
Whereas hold on,
let's finish this job.
I show and then leave the newsletter
this month she'll gets.
Oh,
Paris Hilton.
Huge Joe.
Oprah Winfrey Fan.
Sorry.
Show from combining them.
People think I'm not really Oprah
Winfrey,
Oprah Winfrey.
I think that if I was an old woman who
didn't get any deck,
I think she was God show Oprah.
If I was a 40 year old women,
slightly overweight trying to find,
you know,
sense in my life and religion that
didn't work out for me.
But I just,
Oprah speaks to means,
you know,
I think she's doing the right thing.
Paris blames oxygen for new shows.
Oh,
it's a good show.
It was not a good show,
but it's like so staged,
like so stage
blaming.
She Paris is furious that the show
didn't premier at the time.
It was supposed to listen to this,
she worked her tail off doing promotion
and publicity for the show and then
because of a technical mistake that show
aired in a completely different time and
a lot of markets,
uh,
every fucking TV show on cable,
she's getting pissy because.
Because the way to network the cable
networks work is you premier on the East
Coast at 8:00.
Well then that means on the west coast,
your premieres at 5:00
and then your,
is that like 6:00?
It doesn't work.
Normal.
All the ratings were fucked up for all
those networks because the way cable
setup,
she's just stupid because you do,
she never paid attention to it.
Now stupid.
When did they start dividing shows up
where they would show like,
you know,
lost at 6:00
PM on the east coast,
but 9:00
PM,
you know what I mean?
Like when did,
when did they do that?
Did they use to do it?
Like where,
you know,
they,
the whole country aired cbs at the same
time.
So people had to watch lost at six PM
and La,
is that right?
No,
no,
no.
If you have direct tv then then you will
be able to see the premiere at 5:00.
Of course,
of course,
but what I'm saying is when did they
start switching it up?
When did they start having to
broadcasts?
I think they did that for awhile.
Yeah.
Did they always have to feel that they
had an east coast and the west coast?
I think so because after awhile they'd
probably,
they probably figured out like when do
people want to watch TV?
They get home from work at five ish,
six,
eight,
seven ish.
Eight ish is good.
Eight to 10 inches good and then we're
tired and we got to go to bed or you're
a Weirdo and you hate your life and your
staff and you watch late night.
I don't think they know
at all what they're doing.
Anyone who's programming television,
it has to be demand.
They need to switch it to no way to
figure out what do you like?
Do you really think anyone saw jersey
shore are going to be a hit now?
There's
like people that know,
look,
we just.
UFC just signed a deal at Fox and we
had,
I had a fucking suit,
like a retard.
I look like such a monkey's Fox or Fx,
Fox,
fx and fuel.
So a Fox TV is gonna have the big
fights.
Fx is going to have the ultimate fighter
and a bunch of fight nights and fuel's
going to have some programming on,
on as well.
And a no brainer,
but it's sorta been good.
Those guys,
no fucking sports like when you see like
all the mines comparing notes and trying
to figure out the best way to market
things and push things.
Like there's a level of like they're,
these guys know how to push shows.
They know how to promote shows,
you know,
how to make things happen.
But you're right,
there's a lot of people that are doing
that don't know what the fuck they're
doing,
especially executives when it comes to,
in my opinion,
creative issues where it comes to like
see like comedies and things along those
lines when you have editors or you have
rather,
um,
executives that are interjecting their
ideas.
It almost is never good for the funny.
Almost never,
so they fucked that up,
but it's for sports.
I think they know exactly what the fuck
they're doing.
You know what I mean?
It's like they can affect the outcome.
You know what I'm saying?
Course you're not going to you.
There's no way for an executive to
throws to sense into an MMA fight.
They can't help themselves.
Man.
Their ego is so fucking strong ego that
gets you to the position to be a high
level executive.
Your Ego,
your shelf fucking right.
You're so.
No,
you're fucking right.
You know you're right.
And so it's so hard for them to like
just let you make a show because until
that show is south park where they just
leave it alone because it's a monster
and comedy central.
A guarantee.
They south park probably doesn't even
lead comedy central.
Call them
probably.
You don't have my number.
You don't get my numbers stupid.
Yeah.
It's quite like you don't get my number
dummy just on Tuesday.
I'm going to send a package to you and
it will have the new episode and we'll
do this every week.
That's Louis ck show show.
His deal is earned as a speculation.
It's just,
it's like the rumor mill,
but that he doesn't make a ton of money
but they aren't allowed to touch his
show.
That's amazing.
And everyone needed for sure.
He has to pass it by them.
No,
I know.
He throws it back.
Things that they have,
they've seen him do.
They've accepted that.
He didn't think they were going to
accept.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He did an article where he's talking
about.
It was like,
really?
We can do this.
We can get away with this.
That's the.
It's the fucking ultimate.
I love x now.
That's one of my favorite channels
because they have a lot of good shows
now.
They have the Philadelphia show.
They have there that Louis show and last
night I was watching the Louis show and
deduct Stan hope episode.
Awesome episode,
but I was also watching him talk about
masturbation.
He was using the word calm.
He was talking in great detail,
but she likes to masturbate and stuff
and they're like,
this is awesome.
Fx letting him say I love when people
talk about.
There was no sensory.
No,
there was there,
it was great seeing cable now embracing
that like,
hey,
we're just not going to touch these
show.
Well,
you know,
it doesn't have to.
The FCC doesn't regulate them.
We don't
realize that.
Most people don't realize that.
You see hpo you think that the reason
why hbo has swears is because Hbo the.
Oh,
you pay for it,
so it's okay.
Yeah.
But no,
it's okay.
Through all of cable.
Yeah.
They're just losing their belts though.
These channels are loosening their belts
and seat.
The realizing because the Internet that
people have different sensibilities.
It's just the same people that are
listening to this podcast are also
watching blank on TV.
They're also watching football.
They're also watching baseball.
You know,
I think people are realizing now that
people's sensibilities are a lot
broader.
It's the advertisers is who's taking it
away from him.
Like I think,
I think our,
I don't want to fucking to show,
but I think I heard a
um,
uh,
the league
fucking rent as easy as easy saying
they're gonna do whatever the fuck they
want.
It's just how much are you willing to
lose from advertisers for gain,
you know,
it's,
have to find the right advertisers,
you know,
I mean like the UFC had a hard time
finding the proper advertises for while,
but then they got bud light and then
they get Harley Davidson and you know,
it's now it becomes,
you know,
it becomes something that's easy to,
to,
to connect with,
you know,
it's successful.
It's one something is not successful
yet.
That's when it gets weird.
Like South Park thing.
Dude,
think of some of these shit they've done
on south park.
Think of when they had the whore off,
would that gay guy and Paris Hilton and
he shoved pair of silver in his asshole.
You never that never seen south to sound
park.
It's never seen.
South South Park is,
it is an American gem.
It's,
what's the word I'm looking for?
It's a treasure.
It's a cultural treasure that shows a
cultural treasure.
I don't watch it as much as I should,
but it's fucking
brilliant of art.
I only know.
I can only speak from American Justice
League or team team America,
whatever it was fucking made me laugh.
My team,
America world police,
the funniest fucking thing of all time.
One of the funniest movies of all time.
It's exactly what South Park is.
Yeah,
but I never got into.
I never got it
did genius.
It's genius.
It's the best comedy as far as that kind
of like silly animation type shit that's
ever been created ever.
In my opinion.
I don't think anybody can fuck with
them.
I mean the simpsons obviously are
brilliant and there's a lot of formulas,
but there's still have the simpsons.
I can't watch family guy either.
Oh,
I love that.
I live alone.
If you opened me up,
it's bleeds playing the guy.
It bothers me that South Park likes this
shit on family guy so much.
Sometimes it hurts my feelings and I
like family guy.
Family guy is stupid.
I agree.
It's not as good as South Park.
It's different,
but it's very short attention span.
I could just sit there and just be taken
away on this little silly journey.
You know?
It's a good show,
man.
Family guy is a good show.
I don't know.
I haven't seen American dad either.
I want what I like is that moment when
you realize the brilliance,
like the first time you were watching
family guy,
I was like,
what's this?
And then the joke hit and you're like,
oh fuck,
that's.
So I remember when someone was,
uh,
I think that thing was someone was
choking in the front yard and Peter ran
out and,
and Brian and the dogs sitting there and
Peter runs out and he goes,
don't worry,
I know how to do this.
I can do the Heimlich maneuver.
I read it in a book.
And Brian Goes,
Peter,
you sure you read it in a book,
are you sure?
Just wasn't nothing.
And I heard that and I just started
laughing so fucking hard.
And this wasn't nothing,
nothing.
That's such a weird bug in live.
So I tried to get Leanne to my wife to
watch family guy and she,
she'd sit there and watch it with me and
just didn't get it.
And then the one time where Peter fell
and skinned his knee
for like five minutes anyway.
And then all of a sudden my wife just
starts laughing hysterically and she
goes,
looks at me.
She's like,
how long is he going to do that for it?
I was like,
that's a funny joke.
That's what he's
done is brilliant.
I love those moments where you fucking
get it.
You know,
like the,
we're just clicks in your head and you
go,
oh,
that's funny shit.
Like I want those all the time.
Yeah.
Mcfarland's a cool dude too,
man.
I met him.
I did a voice on a.
I Guess I did myself on,
on wasn't buried meet.
No,
they parodied me on American Dad,
but on family guy came in and actually
did the voice and he was so nice.
He was so cool.
What's it like to be buried?
Parodied?
It was weird.
Well,
it didn't sound anything like me.
It was like I pulled up in a car and I
was drinking and I was like talking
about strippers or something,
which I guess is how they thought of me,
which is kind of funny.
What if he had really hit home and it
really touched.
What if it was me last night it was
drinking.
I was looking for strippers and my
accent did sound anything like me
either.
It's just,
it's just a bad accident.
I would love it if no one's ever been
able to do an impression of me.
You know,
there's certain guys that you can
imitate their voice,
like,
like anyone can do an arnold
schwartzenegger
pressure.
I wish I could do impressions right now.
I totally.
Let's try to do it joe real quick.
You can't do it.
I always.
Jeffrey.
Jeff Richardson was convinced that he
could.
Jeff Bridges was convinced that he could
do it for a while.
He was good at.
He's good at it.
Yes.
He couldn't do me though.
He didn't have it.
I'm sure someone out there could,
but he couldn't.
Yeah.
Morris a and maybe not.
No.
Joe's.
Joe's got a 50 year old woman in like,
hey.
Yeah.
Hi here.
Checked out.
Take time to tell you about all fucking
Duncan trussell's.
Can we just take a second?
Okay.
Appreciate Duncan King.
Obsessed with him.
He.
I could listen.
I listened to him on this and they're
not assessed with him the way he talks.
I want to talk.
He's a.
he's one of my favorite human beings.
He's a fascinating guy.
I listen to this audio.
I'm Ron Bennington's interviewing Penn
Jillette and it was so good.
It was such a good interview that I had
an email pen right afterwards and just
tell him.
I'm like,
dude,
you like,
he is such an interesting guy and he was
talking about so many cool things.
It was really a fun interview man,
but one of the things that he said was
that the person who's in the room,
when you come up with something,
the person who's in the room when you're
bouncing an idea around the person
you're bouncing with has an effect on
that idea.
The person you're in,
the conversation where it's like if
you'd come up with the most brilliant
idea and his thing was that the people
that are like say if you came up with an
idea for something,
the people that were in the room with
you should claim half of that,
that that project.
Totally because you would not have come
up with that project,
you weren't in their presence and I'm
like,
that is so true.
And Duncan trussell's the perfect
example for that,
both with him and with me because Duncan
has always said that like he never goes
as deep into the rabbit hole as he does
when he's on this show
is lavender lavender hour is nothing.
This show it's nothing.
It's.
It is.
It's a lot.
It's a lot lighter.
But man,
when he's talking to you,
you guys go into some deep shit where I
am.
Sometimes they'll give me panic attacks.
He's given me some very interesting
insight on the possibilities,
you know,
and a lot of people say,
well it's just fucking stupid hippie.
What if,
what if talk,
you know,
and that is a lot of it,
but there are,
I'm not sure what this is and I don't
think you are either.
I think you can pretend that you're sure
because it makes you feel better at
night and you can,
you can pretend that everything that you
can't,
you can't hit with a hammer isn't real
and it's just your imagination.
It's just what?
What the fuck is consciousness,
man?
What is this?
What is life?
What is this idea that,
oh,
I'm going to call Bert Kreischer and
asked him to come over to my house and
burt somehow or another navigates his
way through space and time and arrives
at my doorstep and us friends get to
communicate and we're talking into some
fucking thing that takes all of our
voice and all the shit that we say and
throws it through some Internet and
breaks it down to ones and Zeros where
it's then interpreted by other people's
computers in real time.
What the fuck is this?
Don't tell me you know what this is.
This is the bizarreness.
If life wasn't real,
it would be the craziest psychedelic
trip ever.
It's almost like when a real psychedelic
trip is something you're not used to,
something you're not just throws you
off,
but life itself isn't the most uber
bizarre thing ever.
It would seem more plausible to say you
would have many lives in different
parallels and you could travel through
time then to say to someone that we
could talk to you from this room into a
cave like that.
You can send more voices,
like if you'd said pitched everything to
the cave men and you're like,
what's going to be more plausible?
Three guys can then talk and it'll just
travel around the country and everyone
can hear them talk or you just have
another life.
They'll be like,
oh,
fuck another life.
Definitely,
definitely one of another life.
I'm definitely.
I'm deaf.
I completely believe in time travel.
Well,
you know,
they've actually shown like recently the
most recent studies say that the speed
of light cannot be bypassed,
can't,
can't surpass the speed of light.
So they believe that time travel will be
in fact impossible.
But that's just
bullshit.
Fuck your dog.
What else do you want to buy?
A dog knows whether or not they're
correct.
We won't find out for a long time.
Bird crusher.
Hopefully you and I will be alive
though.
Hopefully if we take our vitamins and
eat.
While I want to do those brain pills,
some guy,
I'll give you a bottom.
Some guy that's amazing.
Yeah.
People,
look,
people think it's nuts,
but I can tell you 100 percent that
vitamins have enhanced my,
my,
my feeling,
the way I,
the way my body feels and enhance my
energy.
I believe they give me a call.
My body feels clear.
It feels like it's less needy.
It feels like it's more filled.
When when your body is filled with
nutrients and you're eating healthy,
it works better.
I really truly believe that.
We know that people died of scurvy
because they didn't get enough vitamin
C,
we know that essential nutrients are
very important part of keeping the body
vibrant and healthy and when I eat well
and I've been eating really healthy
lately,
I've been drinking this vitamix thing
every morning and drinking these blended
Kale milkshakes and not milkshakes.
It's just,
it's just blended Kale and cucumbers and
smoothies.
Smoothies and I feel really good and
because I'm giving my body all this
healthy stuff,
it feels like it works better.
When I take these Alpha brain pills,
what they are is nutrients that are
supposed to enhance cerebral function.
Now,
is that a fact?
Man?
I don't.
I don't fucking know and shit.
I can't tell you exactly what mean.
Cognitive function is a very hard thing
to to.
Unless you're testing someone,
you know,
what are you going to do?
You're going to make them perform tasks
and then they're going to give him these
pills and see if they can perform the
tasks.
I guess it'd be you got to factor in all
sorts of other things into account.
How do I know that this guy isn't
stressed out?
How do I know that he's not tired?
How do I know that?
I'll take it for a month and I'll test,
but you know what I'm saying.
I'm doing tests.
It's like you,
you.
That's.
There's other variables in this person's
life,
so you'd have to do a lot of tests,
but the idea behind them is very sound
and that idea is that nutrients can
enhance cognitive function and I think
they can and I think that these pills do
and I know for a fact that I am feeling
good during the day.
I feel like I have even energy and I'm
having dreams man my dreams or a stray
psycho with my grandparents yesterday it
felt like it was real shit.
Do you realize their dreams in the
middle of them?
No,
because I'm doing that all the time,
but the detail was amazing.
Like I,
I was remembering this old photo of my
grandfather I saw a long time ago and he
had the exact same suit on the St Pants
on.
I saw this photo once at my mom's house,
but my mom,
I was telling my mom about it.
She sent me the photo.
I'm like,
that's exactly what I saw my grandfather
wearing and the dream to the exact
detail.
Well,
what is it about remembering the dreams?
Because that's the most shocking.
There's two shocking things that these
pills have done for me is for us to
remember one,
remembering dreams and to being lucid in
the middle of a dream.
I stayed in a dream.
I was in a dream and I stayed in the
dream.
I said,
oh,
well this is just a fucking dream,
and I just.
I didn't even go lucid,
like I didn't try to control it or move
around.
I just let the dream play out,
but I realized it was a dream and I
still didn't wake up.
I have a.
that's a rare thing.
Pills,
just for that.
Dreams.
I have dreams.
I have fucking crazy
dreams,
but I am totally lucid inside my dreams.
Dreams that I'm reading something and
I'll go.
I'll be to go.
Wow,
that's so funny that I'm reading
something because nothing's there in the
dream.
I'll think this.
Nothing's there in my mind is making up
these words,
but I'm still reading them.
That's so interesting.
I had a dream one time that me and Elvis
walked into his potel room and there
were four dudes,
but fucking
right,
and I just hear me who they were.
Be One of the best sentences ever
created.
I had a dream that I was with Elvis and
we walked into his dressing room.
There was four dudes,
but fucking dot,
dot,
dot.
Now hear me out.
It gets weird or they're throwing up in
Burger King Cups just walking each other
and then I.
When I say this,
I fucking just shut the door and I
looked at Elvis.
I go,
what the fuck's going on in your room?
He said to me,
what's your Dream Baby?
Oh Shit.
I wake up,
I wake up.
I'm like,
wake up,
check my.
Make sure it's.
I'm like,
well,
you don't really put me out.
You don't really put me out.
Not that the guys were both fucking
right.
That they didn't know it was the product
placement.
Like what the fuck did Burger King do to
get it?
How the fuck?
What if they figured it out yet?
You
just don't know that there is way to
interject advertising into your dreams
in the future.
Right now it's like I got chrysler
stream about the Elvis and the butt.
Fucking ha ha.
No,
no,
but what is.
There's a possibility that someone could
insert a product to a dream,
right?
They could give you a cheeseburger and
that cheeseburger with some experimental
thing that would make you think about
burger king in a dream and see a burger
and a dream.
Do it.
You can do it.
It's going Geico and shit.
Yes,
in the future,
but that doesn't make any sense because
donald duck noises.
It's Geico.
You have to eat something to have this
happen to you.
We're.
We're missing the whole packet.
We're stumbling on something very
brilliant right now.
Well,
the idea is a possibility,
but it's like,
you know,
100 years in the future,
but 100 years,
if you're drinking booze here,
one of the rare booze pod test,
these guys,
these pussies,
that drinking corona lights,
I got a heineken like a man tall tomboy.
What if you could bring your wife's
brain by talking to her while she slept?
Well,
people think that you can do that.
People think that you can hypnotize
people while they're sleeping and they
believe they can do that.
You know,
hypnosis guys believed that they can
control all sorts of behavior by putting
people under,
so if you are already under and they
started talking to you,
if a guy can really hypnotize you,
that's the book that those comics cannot
be human.
They can't do it too.
You know the kids with anyone.
I don't believe.
No,
no,
no.
You're wrong.
One hundred percent do it for Santos was
a good friend of mine.
He was already to hit the test in a
Bosch and say,
good friend of mine,
a good friend.
That was
a front.
I know,
but I shouldn't say like,
you're a good friend of mine.
I would call you a good friend.
I love you.
You're a great guy.
Good friend of mine.
This guy is just a guy that I worked
with,
but he was a very nice guy and he was.
The only reason why I say this,
if this was.
If he was alive,
I would have stuck with a very good
friend of mine and one of the reasons
why I said is he gave me one of my first
headlining gigs.
He actually booked some clubs back in
Boston and when I was making the
transition between being a middle act on
the road and a headlight and really I
wasn't a headliner as a joke,
I was like,
goddamn amateur.
Really just amateur.
The people are paying money to.
It's only been doing it a few years,
but um,
he was one of the few guys that gave me
one of the first guys to give me a
headline and getting.
But he had a real hypnosis act.
It was legit.
We've talked about it on the podcast
before.
It just wouldn't work with you and it
wouldn't work in the eye.
We think about things too much because
there are people out there waiting to be
led and it's very strange because it
almost seems like some invasion with the
body snatchers,
invasion of the body snatchers type
shit.
There's some people that are on a
different frequency than Uri and you can
talk to those people and you can get
them to believe that they're having sex
with Madonna onstage.
And then the orgasm.
This guy I saw guy orgasm and his pants.
Yeah.
He talks to 100 percent,
paid some money for them.
I'd pay money to someone.
I used to work at stitches comedy Club
in Boston and this guy,
Frank Santos would come in every week
and he would do like,
you know,
he had a Gig,
like maybe it was a Tuesday night or
something like that.
Everyone would feel the way Boston was
in the old days in the golden days of
comedy.
Everyone had a night of the week,
you know,
like Wednesday night would be Kevin Knox
tonight at Nick's comedy stop and one of
the nights was Frank Santos night.
So Frank Santos would come by and we
would sit in the back and watch because
it took comics a while for it to go from
you just start working at the club.
What is this are already did hypnosis
to,
okay,
Frank Santos is onstage,
let's go watch.
Because that,
that.
And that was the natural progression.
Once you realized it was real,
we would always,
if I was outside the room and I knew
that Frank Santos was on the stage,
I had to get in the room to see what he
was going to do because he really could
get people to believe that they were
having sex and he was the r rated
hypnotist.
So it was always,
you know,
you got your,
your,
your lines,
and it was weird because this weird
voice because you barely could
understand it because I wrote those
words together.
Whereas it was together,
wasn't it?
Okay.
Yeah,
it was a boobies are on top of you right
now.
This is where your boobies,
you've got big boobies on top of,
you know,
you're very happy,
very happy and boobies.
Boobies.
And I'm telling you,
these morons really do get hypnotized
and I think it is just easily.
There are some people that their brains
work different than you and I.
You
know what?
I'll tell you what I can tell when I've.
Because lately I've been playing with
fire a little bit on stage.
By the way.
I just want to say this.
I tweeted the link to that documentary
if you want to donate.
That's what I was trying to fucking time
documentary.
Just it's on my twitter so if you want
to donate,
you get Internet savvy bird again,
gonna retweet things with the whatever
you donate,
you get extras with it and it should be
an interesting documentary.
So thank you joe.
So we uh,
but so I don't know if it's because of
the first time we talked and then you
were saying like you,
I don't know if you were into it,
but then lately I've just been playing
with fire on stage to see how far you
can take it.
And it's bizarre.
I don't know if it's hypnotism.
It definitely is inhibited them,
but there are personalities that you can
read from stage and you go that personal
play with me,
you know what I mean?
I'll bring them up.
Like I brought these.
Blockchain might not have ever been as
playful either until they met you and
they just this people that are just
willing to go with it.
Right,
right.
I did a,
I was in Miami and I brought a black
chick and a Puerto Rican checkup on
stage and I had them cut the lights off
and I said,
when you said that you were a little
urban,
and the lady said,
did you notice it?
I notice them on staying mobile phase
and uh,
and I had them cut the lights and I
said,
let's,
let's Improv a threesome.
So let's like,
let's just cut the lights cut.
So it's pitch black so the audience
doesn't see anything.
The audience can't see anything.
It's just,
it's like now it's like a radio show.
So I go,
Oh wow,
that's a great idea.
So I go,
the winters,
what are they saying?
What the father with the waiters are
fucking when at this point when you have
a black ticket to Puerto Rican hot
onstage with a white guy who let's
three,
the waiters are fucking just watching.
So I go,
I go,
all right ladies,
I'm going to go into the bathroom and
shaved my balls.
You guys meet each other and then I give
them the mic and I walked to the corner
of the stage and these fucking chicks
have murdered it.
They were like,
they were like,
how big do you think is digs going to be
the one girl's back not that big.
I bet.
And then like I said,
well you going to do to him and it's
just going back and forth and I'm
sitting in the corner stage one,
it's fucking magic.
I'm not having nothing to do with it.
I have nothing to do with it.
But these girls who come out of their
shells and then I walked back in and I
go,
ladies,
I,
uh,
have shaved my balls,
I want you to take a look.
And then they start making fun of my
Dick and it's just fucking craziness.
But,
but I do believe you can read people
because I,
when I said I don't know if I,
maybe I just,
because I would never do that with a
white person.
I bought it.
Just bring a Puerto Ricans and blacks on
stage.
You wouldn't try and white people.
Like they wouldn't do that.
White people have a tendency to try to
be funny and they and sometimes because
they've listened to my show and it's
sometimes I'll say like edgy shit about
race because I've taken liberties.
They then feel like they can and they'll
drop an f bomb or oh,
it makes me so on.
Urban people are hilarious.
I was at this hotel watching them swim,
the other,
you know,
and he just,
we just trumped line of the day,
urban hotel watching them swim.
I can't wait to hear where this is
going.
It's a special new vacation to the
story.
That's all I want to know is I want to
have a cigarette.
They just sat there and made me laugh
for 30 minutes.
Just watching them swim and having fun.
They're pushing each other in and stuff
like that.
It was hilarious.
One girl had her phone on and she was
trying to hold her phone up above water
so it wouldn't get wet.
And she's like,
well,
you better get this phone for me.
She threw it
country old lady in a kid in the face.
She threw it and hit her on
kid in the face like she was throwing it
out of her friend and it hit her kid.
If the kid starts crying and it's the
sister,
the kid through that kid that was crying
into the pool and I guess that kid can't
swim.
She's like,
throw that kid and it was just nonsense.
It was 30 minutes.
Just stuck with the accent.
Mom and beverly hillbillies to Old Lady,
a squid delayed all the grandmothers in
the corner going through the white guy
just watching those swim and you were
just sitting there taking notes.
It was beautiful.
I was in Atlanta,
was the big hair festival this weekend.
Have you seen the movie good hair?
No.
It's the best movie ever.
Not Best Movie Chris Rock movie.
It's so good.
You learn so much about black women
about it's.
It's,
it's an eyeopening movie and I really
believe every white man,
she'll watch it because you realize how
much white men and black women have in
common about hair.
We all have issues with our fucking
hair.
I was sitting next to Vivica Fox on a
plane one time and we just ended up
talking about the stuff.
Sometimes I'll use a sprint.
What's a super millionaires?
I sprinkle it in my hair and like I use
that to will call you.
You use.
I was like,
I use like Fox were exchanging Vivica
functions.
Like you got to use two colors.
It makes it look more natural.
Like,
oh thank you.
So,
but that whole hair convention was
happening in Atlanta.
There was a hair convention.
Hair convention.
Black women have a hard when it comes to
hair,
if they can't like sleep,
just go to bed.
They're going to like sleep sitting up
like what the fuck are you talking
about?
A black woman with a thing of hair,
like a good hairstyle.
You can't just fucking go to bed.
They'll sleep sitting up.
This movie's amazing.
So yes,
and first of all,
I mean I'm making generalizations right
now that I don't want them to sound
racist or I want them to sound like I
watched a movie about this and I'm.
And I maybe didn't pay attention all
that well,
but they get all their hair from Indian
people.
Like in the middle.
It can be you mean?
Yeah.
And weeds are expensive as shit.
And the brothers got to pay for that
shit.
Like the.
It is weird that we have decided that
white girl,
that black women have to have white girl
hair.
Yeah.
It's so fucking crazy.
Black eyes are allowed to have black
hair.
He for a while they didn't like sugar
ray Robinson.
These to have a conch.
These to like put some chemicals in
their hair to straighten their hair out.
And guys like black guys would comb
their hair like a white guy.
Have you seen beyonce lately?
She has blonde hair now.
If you look at her album,
like from whatever five years ago.
And you look at our album now,
it looks like Micheal Jackson,
black and white.
She's now like gold skin,
blonde hair.
She looks like a white person now.
And then you look at her old album and
it looks like she's swimming in a pool
and she thinks she's lightening your
skin.
It it seems like at orange sheet or
their photoshopping fuck out everything
to photoshop crazy photoshopping her
because she does not look black.
Get on.
I can't blackface,
black girl hair.
One thing again,
they have black hair.
You know,
why does it have to be.
Be like some do,
but I think.
I think,
I mean it's just totally outright
better.
We've got to be so brutal man.
Have you seen the feathers,
Dick?
Have you seen the feathers?
There's this new trend now.
Girls are wearing fucking feathers.
Like they're fucking egos and shit.
It's the dumbest shit ever.
Like I keep saying this.
How many feathers?
It's got attacked by a Falcon Philly and
she had a raccoon tail.
I guess that's popular right now.
We this raccoon tail from your film?
Yeah.
Kids are wearing these raccoon tails.
Like they're animals.
Like they're fucking Mario brothers.
Like the raccoons.
They have raccoon tails and then this
girl had a raccoon tail and feathers in
her hair.
Wow.
They're like on their way to being a
furry but not quite there yet.
Baby-Step furries was just wearing
raccoon tails.
There's some people that just one little
thing will help them feel a little bit
better man.
And if it's a raccoon tail I say,
put that thing on.
Don't shoot yourself in the head.
Get yourself through this.
If you need to fucking raccoon tail to
make you feel happy,
then put it on.
Son.
What are you?
Uh,
are you a Fox?
You are a man.
Police were to have a nice day.
I would love to see you in the chimps.
Don't have tails.
Foxtown.
Champs tone.
That tells the animal on the chimp.
What'd you get?
A little chimp?
Nope.
Just like a little nub of a tail that
they would wear a prosthetic asshole
that swells in estrus.
I wouldn't be willing to do that,
but I think that's only for the female.
I think the female,
her butthole,
her nether regions death swell and
become enlarged.
And the gorge and I tell the mail chimp
knows it's time to get freaky.
He got caught watching dogs.
Fuck on youtube videos watching dogs.
Fuck.
You've caught yourself watching like
four minutes to dogs.
Fuck
playlist off dog.
Fucking playlist on Youtube.
You just fucking said it there and get
stoned and watch a bunch of dogs.
Fuck man.
It's kind of funny that we can't watch
people.
Fuck,
you know,
you put people fucking on Youtube.
They'll pull that shit right off.
Did they just pull Tripoli's all if his
whole entire youtube account they pulled
the whole entire time once because he
had this thing called master tents
theater where it was girls with like
eyeballs glued onto their boobs and it
looked like their like their faces and
stuff like that and they pulled it from
that and just just through long.
You don't show the nipple
though.
They ain't do that.
I guess not.
And that other girl nipple,
you can shut down to youtube type in
breastfeeding.
It was a seven year old soccer tit.
Well,
you know that's funny because youtube
was very rarely pulled down any of my
videos,
but one they pulled down was one that I
put said Joe Rogan drinks piss.
I saw that video.
I saw that video and I trained.
I put it back up under the title of
urine therapy and they let it go
through.
Go through.
Yeah,
that's,
I don't know if I can drink my own piss
[inaudible] right now.
We get it.
What in your eye?
I looked at him.
I said,
come on,
let's do it right now.
And he had a sparkle in your eye.
Like,
Oh yeah,
we're doing this marriage.
Yeah.
There was a moment,
man,
where you realize we just entered into
that chaotic world that you're so
comfortable with you.
You loved that world,
man.
You locked onto that.
You locked onto that moment.
That's why you could do that.
So.
Well,
age man,
because I.
because I just can't say it.
I have a hard time when we were at the
know you like chaos,
love and enjoy it.
This guy,
the at the,
at the braves game ball.
That's going to fucking go everywhere.
No,
I think you're a skier.
At the braves game,
gay beer came running up to me.
We're in the porch,
the chophouse at the end and the back
end,
the outfield.
He comes running and he's like machine
and I go,
hey man.
And he goes,
oh,
fuck him up.
We got to do a shot right now.
It's the middle of afternoon,
I a Sunday show and I'm like,
I can't man,
and he goes,
come on some machine and I go,
all right,
let's fucking do it.
And that my friends go,
I just watched you fold so fucking
quick.
I was like,
well,
you said to machine.
I mean,
how do I not like we're brothers now.
You and I both have that same issue too,
that your party guys too.
We're both chaos people.
I mean there's a thousand videos of me
is screaming at people on Youtube and
and audiences and hecklers and stuff.
When I was in Milwaukee,
the show,
it was a,
it was a great audience.
Let me just.
It was a weird thing and then it got
crazy and people yelling things out left
and right,
but before that there they're laughing
and everything.
They're like a great crowd.
There's just a few crazy drunk
knuckleheads and it eventually wound up
being like one of these question and
answer type things where you know,
people,
people are yelling things out.
I'm talking to them,
but people like that and you know what
they like about it.
They like when they have,
they know that you brought these girls
out of the audience there onstage with
you and you're off in the corner shaving
your balls.
They know that this is just coming out
of nowhere.
That's what I know,
but it.
But it makes it,
it makes it like.
I almost feel like it's a,
it's like shooting heroin,
like doing standard smoking,
heroin.
Then you get someone on stage and you
have this real fucking moment where you
got three gangbangers dicks out and
they're fucking real talk.
Mother fucker is the three.
Oh five.
And you're like,
do you have guys had their dicks out on
stage?
Yeah,
I told you that one time.
Yeah.
Explain that again.
What happened?
I was in Miami.
Miami's my crazy fucking place.
I've,
I,
it just chaos happens in Miami.
Yeah.
Miami,
if you want to starve to death,
open up a bookstore in Miami.
Fucking jokes are so good.
How does that work that you say that?
No,
you.
If you want to start done.
It was like,
where's he going with this?
And then you switch it.
My brain starts going,
oh,
time to giggle.
What does,
how does that work?
It's time to Giggle,
but other night.
Let's fuck.
Let's put it on
Carola's reading glasses and see if we
can solve this with Adam Carolla here.
Yeah,
man.
I get fucking a-listers here.
I've got an issue.
My eyes are really bad.
He needs reading glasses really bad.
But.
But like there was this thing where he's
like looking at the receipt.
Like,
what's this say right here?
Well,
I can't see in low light in the
highlight conditions is absolute true
and highlight conditions.
My,
my eyes were great,
but in low light conditions have a
really hard time reading now.
I think it looks great.
I think that's going to be your new
style.
You're going to be one of those guys
like random problems.
My problem is that my eyes and Adam
crawls eyes are in the same state of
deterioration.
Yeah.
I thought it was a big guy.
Wow.
This is so much better,
right?
Yeah.
You need.
It might do.
You could just get Oakley a rims and
then just tell me what those.
Uh,
Linda.
No,
you don't.
You don't want to wear them so sad.
You've got to get the ones that flip up
and fold up like old congressmen have.
Yeah,
I can read this easily,
but not.
It's not as clear.
My Dad has these glasses.
They're magical.
They go one side as far sided.
One side is normal,
so yeah,
if he ever wants to read something in
the 30 some magic,
there's a man named Harry Potter and
lives in the castle and he solved the
problem of vision.
The warlock lenscrafters gave it to.
I wonder men,
the first dude to come up with glasses,
man.
He must've been a goddamn wizard.
Who's the first guy that got girls to
swallow?
That shit's been going on since the
stone age.
There's no one who could hold claim to
that.
There's probably a few charlatans from
the 15 hundreds.
I was the first.
No,
no,
no.
The cave man bitches were sucking dicks
and swollen loads.
Loads contain nutrients.
Back then you had to learn hard to stay
alive.
GNC,
you drank your piercing.
He swallowed other people's loads.
Whatever.
You don't like it,
but I just want to be healthy.
It's tapioca pudding son,
Alphacam
baby.
Oh,
Alpha Alpha nails with my Alphacam.
So you noticed with those pills,
those pills.
I,
you know what,
there's a lot of people online that are
like crying about it because they will
know no one who's known as Tegan is
crying about it.
Right?
Exactly.
That's what I'm saying.
Guy I met loves it.
He don't want to believe that there's
something that you can take that can
actually enhance brain function.
Like this would be like the biggest
thing that ever happened.
Neuroscience,
we're not talking about some limitless
pill that you take and all of a sudden
you're super genius,
but we're talking about is you when you
don't.
You have moments where you feel at your
best.
Yeah.
Did you?
But it's at your best.
You're not on steroids.
You're not on limitless.
You not on some craziest,
but it's you at your best and those
moments are hard to attain and I think
they have a lot to do with rest and
nutrition.
I think you at your best has to do with
what your body is processing.
What is it?
Processing good foods and vegetables and
vitamins and everything is smooth and
easy.
It's got everything.
It's required and when you do that,
things work
better.
I started,
I started not drinking on Thursday and
Friday and Saturday,
Friday,
Saturday.
I blow it out a bit on stage.
Definitely not drinking on Thursday.
Going up on stage too much.
Is that going to bed,
getting a good night's sleep,
working out Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday workout every single day.
Eat healthy at the clubs and then
whatever I can get around the club,
around the hotel.
I did it.
I'm grant funding.
I did it one weekend but,
but,
but I felt good.
I felt really good and I thought I
started thinking,
you know,
that there is something to that.
Because this last weekend in Atlanta,
I was on a bender,
a drink every morning.
I drank every morning on radio.
I drank every,
every evening on stage.
I spent the whole night out all night
and then every day like my friends would
come down and we'd go drinking or Jesus.
It was,
it was a bender.
Didn't drink pedialyte.
No.
You know what,
man,
I wonder if I'm dehydrated as fuck.
Of course you will.
Yeah.
Just start drinking fucking a coconut
water coconut water right now.
Uh,
well.
Don't want to interrupt my beers.
The um,
the.
Yeah,
I started doing that.
And then.
And then you don't want any drink on
flights or drink complains heavily.
I drank.
I tried to slow down today because I was
like drink.
It's panic but.
And that helps you know,
fix it.
But I was like,
I don't wanna be a mess when I show up
at your house and just be like fucking.
I was hoping you were going to be a
mess.
Trust me when I say that.
I'm a good mess.
I'm a fun math madness.
Yeah.
There's some people that I would say
you're drinking.
Um,
let's do this tomorrow.
I'll do it tomorrow.
Did,
but you're not that guy.
Do you know what?
My Dad gave me a pony a
me softly and show you where to go back
to the old family field.
Richard Dawson.
Did
you.
You sent me that shit about Andy Dick by
the way.
What the fuck was going on?
Tell me exactly what happened was I was
watching it on the plane so I didn't
really get the whole thing,
but andy was on.
Greg Fitzsimmons only said he was a Jew
and they off on that,
kept going
on about hook nose Jew and calling them
a hook known to look.
Andy is obviously in a tail spin right
now.
He's in a downward spiral,
you know,
he keeps getting.
He got sober when he was on our show who
was sober and then afterwards he got
arrested.
Did Ab maybe got arrested?
I mean maybe he was.
Yeah.
You don't think he was so.
But you think he was cooking up?
I don't think.
I don't know what he was and I don't
want to say he was,
but I do know he has the biggest,
a urinary track infection I've ever
seen.
Then because he keeps.
He went to the back of my four times.
He could've been doing something there.
He maybe he did that for confidence.
Who's worried about,
you know,
he had talked to a lot of shit about me
and then all of sudden is going to be on
a podcast and he also,
because he also,
the only reason I ever think this is
because I noticed that he went to the
bathroom four times,
but that also that he was saying he was
sober,
but then people at the comedy store is
like,
dude,
he was blacking out here last year,
last night when you told him
me that about that,
that people did at the comedy store.
Psalm all fucked up.
You know,
Andy and I have a lot of history and uh,
I understand Andy in a way that very few
people do.
And I,
I,
when I,
when I say that I honestly loved the guy
and I wish them the best.
I honestly do.
I really do.
And he's a,
he's a good person and his best moments,
you know,
he's just crazy as fuck.
And he blames me for a lot of,
like his bad times when he was on news
radio and he's like,
he is so angry.
He was so mean to me.
He doesn't realize he was constantly
pushing my buttons.
He was constantly fucking with me and he
was doing it because it's just in his
nature.
He had a,
an insane childhood and I don't know the
full details,
but I know it was not good and you know,
because of that he's,
you know,
become this incredibly talented,
gifted,
sort of a needy cat.
And uh,
our,
our relationship has always been very
strange,
you know,
like he literally bang on my trailer
door,
opened it up and he had his dick in his
hand,
but you do understand.
Friend was in the,
in the room and he's like,
can you guys fuck?
And he's like,
try,
I mean it was fucking serious.
But you do understand that even though
when he was on the show that might've
been like to you,
but that was in lot of people's
opinions,
the best fucking duo ever watching you
and gather.
It's probably one of the best things
I've ever seen in my whole entire life.
Interesting.
When we did the show and we did the
show,
we had this weird love hate
relationship.
Like Andy could make me laugh harder
than anybody.
Man,
when we did scenes together,
I would have to redo things like three
or four times because I couldn't stop
cracking up.
I couldn't help myself.
We had this one where there was pencils.
I had pencils in my hand and one of them
was obviously way longer than the other
one,
which is the longest one is like the
attack and it gets in my face and he's
like,
it's just studying it and I couldn't
stop laughing.
He's fucking brilliant.
Oh
Man.
I remember falling in love with that
show.
He's not that guy anymore.
He's now he's Andy at 50 or whatever.
It is.
So sad.
What did he say?
I mean,
what's that look?
Here's the root of it.
Forget all
the words that came out.
What's the intention behind it?
The intention behind it is to lash out
at Howard stern so that Howard stern in
turn lashes back and maybe there's room
for reconciliation and all this is just
giant sums of attention.
If it was money,
it would be a financial downpour.
It's attention.
That's what it is,
and he probably doesn't even realize it
when he's saying it,
but Howard starting to do anything to
him and he's,
you know,
what did I mean?
Did he owe money?
Oh No,
no.
Howard stern doesn't know a fucking say
human.
He called him when Charlie Sheen was one
the show and wanted to like put his,
he just wanted attention when Charlie
Sheen was darn electronic,
Jane or Charlie Sheen was there and uh,
and Howard wouldn't take the call and he
said something like,
Andy's,
you know,
why are we going to take listen to him?
He's living in a fucking trailer in the
back of his house.
He is or whatever.
And then Andy got upset,
lashed out at,
at Howard all greg show.
And I heard Howard talk about it and I
really,
it really was like,
you know,
it almost sounded like Michael Richards
when he tried to like,
you know,
the nigger thing,
almost bain,
but it's super sad.
I don't even want to say it's sad.
It's just because I don't want,
I wouldn't want to put that energy out
there,
but it is because man Andy was,
was so fucking talented.
He still towns,
he's just crazy.
Some layers.
It still cracks me up.
I don't care if he's sober.
He's still cracks me up.
He's not doing good right now.
That's what the problem is.
If he was doing good,
if he was on a sitcom right now and he's
making
tons of cash and you know,
and he could fuck off and then pull it
back together again,
he'd be okay.
The problem is right now he's not on st
and he's in.
He's in a bad place.
It's not good and so he's lashing out
with Howard Stern.
I think the lesson is don't ever tell
people you're quitting drinking.
Just quote
he was he,
he did it and then he would say,
you know,
I'm not saying it's forever.
I don't know though.
His response,
like Howard Stern's response to it.
That kind of freaked me out because it's
like,
dude,
why are you going off on,
what was it?
Thirty minutes,
40 minutes.
You immediately snapped and now like
this guy that you obviously know it's
fucked up,
you're fucking destroying him in 30
minutes and like him and robin just like
Kinda tore andy apart.
Like I was like,
you have to understand where Andy is
right now.
And like,
like you pretty much exposed yourself
and just saying like,
all right,
you don't give a shit about this dude.
So even if you have some qualms with
this guy,
you just pretty much just expose
yourself as like thinking this guy is
the worst person in the room.
At least that's what I got from it.
I don't understand what you're saying.
He just,
he just,
he,
he like,
he really focused on what Andy said
about being a Jew or being like a Jew
Hook,
nose,
Jew or whatever he like.
And if you look at old school,
Howard Stern,
Howard stern was the first person to
like make fun of blacks.
Make Fun of fucking Italians.
Make Fun.
Like,
like Howard used to be like this risky
guy and he focused so much on like being
called a Jew,
like,
like it,
like it seemed like the whole thing was
because of that,
like some anger at.
Okay.
You know what I'm talking about?
Like kind of misordered knowing you're
talking about.
But honestly
when I was hearing that I was the,
first of all,
I was like,
this is so low level.
This is such a low level move to ses at
Julie's a hook,
nose Jew.
I was like,
come on man,
this is like,
this is,
this is just more on shit.
And it's like you're,
you're,
you're just going after this stuff that
he goes after about himself and you're
going after it and you're saying he's
got a sore spot.
They're like,
what is this?
It's just idiotic because what it is.
But his reaction to it,
you gotta realize Howard Stern is an old
school dude.
You know,
he's older than us,
man.
He's been around a long time,
pre internet and he grew up in a fucking
black community man.
So you know,
that kind of racist or calling them a
Jew,
calling them a Jew is.
It doesn't feel good man.
It feels fucking shitty and it feels
like something that he has to defend.
And when he says that,
if anybody,
if this guy did this rant about any
other ethnicity,
if he did this rant about black people,
he would be all over the fucking news.
People would be talking about let's
blackball hamlet's never hire him again
because he's running off at the mouth
about Jews.
Nobody cares.
Because the presumption is that Jews run
show business anyway.
Oh poor,
you know,
$500.
Millionaire,
Howard Stern.
It gets called a Jew,
you know?
Oh,
you're going to be okay.
You know,
that's the presumption.
You don't know when you really.
I agree with Howard though.
I think,
you know,
you got to point it out.
If this was,
if he was talking to my gaze and he
wasn't gay,
but he was gay.
So if he is gay,
wouldn't you know,
Andy talked about gays,
that they'd be like,
whatever,
you know what I mean?
But he had sort of gay gay style
sometimes at times every day being in
the podcasts and it him sitting next to
me and going,
oh,
so attracted to you
going back.
No fucking way.
No Way.
Never do that.
You never.
No,
no,
no.
That's it.
There's nothing good about killing him
with my hands.
Fuck.
He always scared for you go to jail.
There's no follow up to that interview.
No,
I'm just saying that you thought the
interview was really awful.
No,
no,
no.
It was uncomfortable for me,
but I didn't think it was an
interesting,
very funny.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
And he's hilarious.
Look,
if Andy and I,
you know,
if this is a true story,
this is a true statement.
Rather if a sitcom came up and they said
we want to do a sitcom with you and andy
and we're pretty sure we've got andy
under control and Andy is talking to a
therapist and he's on this new thing
that's called Zoloft,
Tinian
fucking insights.
A lot of Zoloft.
And apparently it's totally leveled them
out,
but he's funnier than ever.
And they let her.
I smoke pot.
He's only allowed to smoke pot.
I'd be like,
wow,
okay.
What network?
I swear to God,
man,
I loved working with that guy.
But if he said all those things,
what about
Howard that he said about me?
It wouldn't hurt me as much as it hurt
Howard or make me as man because I know
who he is.
I know you can't trick me with a bunch
of noise that comes out of your mouth.
I know where it all comes from.
I know.
I know the fiber of his being in these
crazy.
He's crazy as fuck.
You know,
and he didn't know what he really means
by all this.
As he feels abandoned,
he's got nothing going on.
And so he lashes out and he says fucked
up shit like that.
But that's really what it is.
So when,
when Howard got all mad and you know,
and,
and freaked out about it,
I saw his point,
but I also saw a point where someone
needs to be right next to Howard going,
dude,
not about this guy,
this guy to go over this,
get out.
Because he was going off about like,
you know,
number one in the market,
have you try going into a market and
become number one,
why all these comedians on Corolla?
Yeah.
He was going off about why these
comedians are jealous of me.
Why know?
Why do they say things about me?
Look,
here's the deal.
Like if you walk around my house,
man,
you'll see lenny bruce all over the
place you've been.
You've seen these posters that have
happened.
I don't want to sit around listening to
lenny.
Bruce.
Okay.
I don't,
I don't.
It's not like I listen to them every
day,
but in my mind,
the only way I would've ever gotten to
do what I'm doing with my life is if
there was some bad mother fucker from
the sixties,
some crazy Jew named lenny bruce and
this motherfucker was such a bad ass and
a risk taker.
It didn't.
He got arrested.
They put them in jail for saying certain
words.
He was a guy who got on stage in front
of a bunch of people in a mixed audience
and started calling.
Where are the niggers were the
negatives?
Whereas a nigger over here,
we've got a Nigga over there.
We've got a Nigga over here,
we have a Nigga,
we gotta,
we gotta jude.
We got kick.
Here's a kite.
We gotta go over here.
Really?
He would.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was with a spic dirty spic right
there.
That's like,
here's a SPEC.
Here's a walk.
We got New Guinea wop.
We've got a Jew,
a giddy up.
We got two niggas.
Are you saying?
He said,
and he said that he had this whole bit
about.
If you say that enough,
then it's not going to hurt a little
kid's feelings.
It won't be so shocking.
Will take away the power from this
stupid word.
He was the first guy to use a joke
about.
There's two jokes that I've heard that
people ripped off.
They probably didn't even realize they
ripped off,
but they were lenny bruce jokes.
One of them was he goes,
being a homosexual is illegal.
Dig.
So what would happen is when the see
someone,
they arrest you,
they put you in jail,
but men want to have sex with you mean
we can't.
In our.
In our context of our society in 2011,
our,
our level of social evolution,
we're far beyond where we were in the
sixties,
but this guy in the sixties was fucking
revolutionary and so that's why I have
posters of money,
bruises all over my house.
If you want to talk about radio,
there's only one guy you want to talk
about and that's Howard stern and that
is a fact.
I don't give a fuck what you say.
That guy is revolutionary.
He's the one guy who stepped in when
everybody was doing the same stupid shit
and he took chances.
He did crazy shit.
He,
he went deep and dark and it's not
because he really means all the things
that he's saying he wants to putting
on a show,
extreme entertainment,
extreme and attainment,
but in doing so,
you put out a lot of you.
You take a lot of chances,
you expose yourself and you become very
sensitive and through all of his
attacks,
I think he's become more sensitive
because I don't think that Howard stern
of 10,
15 years ago would have reacted the way
he reacted to any deck.
Now I think he would mock Andy Dick
because I think,
I don't want to say he was correcting
who is incorrect,
but if Andy says something about me like
that,
I would have it on and I would start
laughing and say I need to call
Dick.
Well,
life counselor was thinking,
what do I need to do to get my life in
order?
Well,
I'm a hook.
No Jew is fix the sandy.
You know,
like,
what the fuck are you trying to say?
Not only that,
here's a guy living in a shed who's
giving this advice out,
which just makes it even more ironic.
That's marriage.
Do you think that's him?
Him and Howard death.
Who the fuck do I know?
I'm not wanting to come.
I don't know him that well.
If I knew him that well,
it do a show more often.
I don't know him that well.
She's older.
Yeah.
Once you get older,
you're going to extreme human being,
man.
He's an extreme example of what's
possible.
There's in any sport,
man,
you know,
but it's,
oh Michael Jordan's a douche bag.
But you know what,
Michael Jordan can dunk from fucking
half court,
so shut the fuck up here.
We don't know why that guy's a Douche
bag and I'm not.
I'm not giving him a free pass.
I'm not giving anyone a free pass,
but excellent examples of human beings
in any form that doesn't.
They don't come balanced.
Okay?
For someone to reach the highest heights
and set the standards in a way that have
not been set before,
whether it's through comedy or music or
radio or anything,
that person,
that fucking purse,
that pioneer way at the front of the
line,
running through barriers,
that guy's not going to be balanced
because if it was balanced,
you wouldn't have the energy to get
there.
The way you have the energy to get there
is that you are imbalanced.
So you've got to respect that man.
You know,
and then you have to grade things on a
curve and you should judge people based
on their accomplishments almost as much
as you judge them based on their
personality to personality is what's
most important.
If you want to be around them for sure
you know,
you don't want someone to around you
that wants to be the king of the world
and once you know all the conversations
to be about him,
but he got to realize that in order to
start some giant mega corporation in
order to,
you know,
to be the guy at the head of Halliburton
when you really have to be that guy.
There's this,
it's not possible without.
You can't,
it's not,
not as.
You can't just,
I,
you know,
I say that sometimes about nine.
None of this is really downplaying it,
but about standup in order to want to
stand in front of a group of strangers
for an hour and speak something fucked
up with you.
Dude.
I say it on stage.
I do a whole bit about it.
How ridiculous it is that here I am,
I'm saying,
well,
I want a job where I'm the only one who
gets to talk for an hour in front of a
bunch of people.
You're right there.
This is not like the Internet.
Like right now we've isolated this
situation where there's only three of us
in my office and we're hanging out
talking,
but when you're on stage,
man,
I'll do that shit in front of a thousand
people,
2000 people,
even there's 2000 people in the
audience.
I'm talking and they don't give a shit.
The weirdest scenario in the world is my
friends.
I went out with a bunch of friends.
All my friends are single and Atlanta.
Single and fucking rich as fuck.
Like these criminals.
Do.
They know they own bars.
Like my one buddy owns a bunch of bars
called Tin Lizzy's because they owned
bars.
They're all just wealthy.
They're just single guys who have
nothing but disposable income,
but what are there?
The reason why I'm asking that because
the reason why they're single.
A lot of people in the bar business or
fucking single.
Yeah,
I know.
I think he got into the bar business
because he's single not.
You know what I mean?
I don't think has any.
I don't think there's any.
He wanted to make money,
but he also was like,
fuck,
it's a great way to meet chicks.
He opened like one of the biggest parts
of Atlanta back in like,
like when email just started,
he owned a bar and he got everyone's
email addresses and so now he's locked
down Atlanta.
There was a dude who wrote a post on the
underground forum about
this chick that he dated that was in a
bar.
She was so she worked in a,
as a waitress in a bar and that over the
years he watched her change over the
years of being in that environment and
constantly being around party pitbulls
and constantly being around the light
and the nightlife that he watched her
change and I'm like,
man,
that is got to be one of the most
depressing things in the world.
Do you being in love with a chick,
you're living with her and watching her
change because she's around all these
rich guys that are trying to stick their
dick under her.
So every night they're dancing.
The Devil's dance.
They got fucking fired,
redness,
a Ferrari,
and after a while there,
even though she loves her man,
there is a real resentment that builds
up.
Why can't the man that I love provided
me with the Ferrari?
Why can't the man that I love giving me
this House that this guy could give me
if I just took that evil Dick,
that dirty,
scaly,
scratchy for covered cock,
like a little wolverine.
Dick's,
Dick's inside of just a monster man,
some fucking horrible person that just
wants to get money and money and money
dancing the dance,
and every night she sees these guys
dancing,
dance,
throwing thousand dollars,
tips her way and she didn't.
Come on baby.
Any night I'll take you away from this.
You don't look at it.
I'm looking at settle down.
I'm looking to get out of this game.
Private jets.
Yeah man.
This dudes that will show up at
nightclubs especially,
you know Miami.
Miami's a Goddamn joke.
This dude's flying in on private planes
from all over the world.
Just to be a baller in Miami.
There's a few spots in the world where
it's like,
it's a clutch move to show up and be a
baller,
you know,
where people will fly in the super
elite,
ultra billionaire type characters that,
you know,
we'll fly in during conn and France.
I want to be,
don't,
don't you kind of want to try it once,
but like just be,
I want to be the guy that rolls in on a
private jet.
Like I was with my friends and I was
watching them.
They're all,
they're all,
they're all fucking liquid.
No kids,
no nothing.
No.
Don't worry about anything and end this
whole time I'm a news stand up.
They've been spitting game of bitches.
So this,
this
gentleman known as the urban influence.
Whole time I've been doing this comedy
thing.
They've been spitting game at bitches.
They're game is soul time.
You got married and had this whole time.
So like we all went out to the.
One of my buddies bars and Mike and I
watched them operate with women in
watching a pro on stage.
Yeah.
But do you know what dude?
That's all nonsense.
You know they have card tricks.
You're Bert Kreischer.
You're a fucking comedian.
You know what I'm saying?
Do you understand that they can't be
jealous and these guys are good at
bullshitting.
They have to bullshit.
All you have to do is go,
ladies,
I'm onstage.
Where's the shot's cut?
Two or three hours later,
you hotel room,
one girl locked onto your balls like one
of those land in the bottom of a shark
and the other ones suck it on your shaft
and you squirt while you throw your arms
up in the air and victory right here.
One of the girls go,
powerful burt Chrysler,
Chrysler.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck your friends in their bars.
You're Bert Kreischer.
If you were single dude,
you'd be doing damage right now,
son.
You would be doing.
Oh,
you didn't have the little babies and
the wife and the whole,
the whole package.
And he went out there and like the whole
pack.
Look,
I love the whole package so people don't
believe that I.
You know,
you don't think that you would,
but you do.
It's like being.
It's like,
it's like almost like being an alcoholic
or a Christian,
but you can only connect.
Like I tried to tell my friends like how
great it is and they just don't see this
guy.
I'm,
I'm good.
It's not for everybody.
You know?
I,
I used to hate when people who had kids
would say that the only way to live a
fulfilled life is to have children,
but I think that's preposterous and I
still do.
Do you believe it's the only way to
fucking.
I haven't touched this one here.
Take this one.
It's not the only way.
It's ridiculous.
Why don't you just suck on that before
it spills all over my goddamn table.
Son.
You got to.
You're on your own iphone.
Their fellow.
No,
this is yours.
I think crusher.
Sloppy drunk.
No,
I just,
um,
you know what's so funny is my iphone.
You Fuck?
Igor taught me how to.
What's a foreign bottle like that?
What's a fun off the side?
That's where you going to tell me no
ego.
I told you that last week.
Didn't the side of the table.
No beer bottle of beer bottle robin to
get a Napkin.
Oh,
don't worry about it dude.
Okay,
grab that towel off
the wall.
Grab the towel.
Just don't lose the blue angels photo.
That shit's important man.
Best wishes from the blue angels.
February 22nd,
1999.
Folks.
I flew in an f 18,
seven and a half g's.
I had a whole bit about it.
I did.
And one of my specials back in the
design was true,
man.
I was incredible.
You realize how fast those fucking
things go.
You can't even wrap your head around it,
man.
Who we were.
Um,
and these guys were started.
Man.
These fucking dudes.
Who are these,
these fighter pilots.
I can't be over a certain height because
you have to,
uh,
maximize the amount of g force you can
take.
You should be short.
So you can do that.
The hooking thing where you hold onto
the thing or just what the fuck that
what you're doing is as you're hitting
that,
Geez,
you're doing what's called hooking and
you're holding onto the handle and to go
on this and what you're doing is forcing
blood into your brain because the
pressure of the g force is literally
pushing the blood out of your brain.
I think that would make me black out.
It course it was.
That's it does make you.
But will that keeps you alive under,
under normal conditions.
Maybe that would make you black enough.
I don't think it will,
but the,
the,
the pressure is with trying to get you
to blackout and the hooking is what
makes you stay alive.
And uh,
we were um,
we were flying in his fucking fat and we
did some crazy drills.
Man,
were we,
one time we hit,
we went to,
we went to five and he goes,
you cool with five?
I can handle five and went to six.
You know,
you're cool with sex.
I go,
I did it.
I did.
He's like,
Oh,
I'm going to take this up.
I'm gonna take this out,
and we went to seven and a half g's,
but he was hooking to.
That's what it was freaky to.
He was going through this.
Then you could.
You could see consciousness like an
elevator door.
You could see there was darkness on
either side
side.
Getting choked out.
Yeah,
exactly.
He's choked me out.
That fucking freaked me out.
You watch it go close and then it's
almost like you're dancing.
You're head's on the.
You're.
You're buried.
Your body's buried your head bay and
you're dancing.
There's a whole world underneath you to
stairs that go down and then you got
them back up and you're like,
Hey,
what happened?
Well,
you get a little tiny dose of
psychedelic is what happens when you get
choked out.
You have little dreams.
Have Weird things.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Have you ever been choked out?
No.
Check yourself.
Never been choked.
Unconscious Joe.
No.
Never told me to do it too.
You know,
I've done it lot.
It's a tap.
I'm not stupid.
I know when I'm going out,
when I'm going out,
I just tapped.
But it could happen.
It could happen tonight.
I'm going to class tonight.
I get choked unconscious tonight and
happens all the time.
Oh Man.
He ain't get choked out or.
Yeah,
let's.
let's do that.
You should do Jujitsu,
man.
I've been thinking about it.
Fuck yeah man.
A lot of my head of one of my friends
who got the the laughing skull and
Atlanta's is massively into Jujitsu and
he's like,
you know,
it calms me down a,
a lot of energy and angry energy.
And he goes,
the other day a guy got really pissed
about his bar tab at the club and he got
my face and he's like,
I just didn't like.
There was no anger towards him.
I was just like,
listen man,
we're fine.
You know,
like he,
he's like,
it centered me.
I've been thinking about it.
My problem is I'm not around anywhere.
I don't know it on the road.
I'd be,
I'd be at the brand new.
I'd be the fucking punching bag.
Every.
Yeah.
Every day.
It's good for you.
Good for you to get your ass kicked.
Really?
Yeah.
It's good for you to know how easy it is
for man.
Kick your ass to eyes,
good for you,
good for you to get destroyed,
as good for you to get mounted.
Triangle choked and shit.
It's good because you realize how easy
it is for someone to do that to you
because most people have no idea they
walked through this world.
Having no idea how
summer Marcello Garcia character could
just fucking take your life anytime he
wanted to and not just take your life.
How about this?
How about taking my life?
What I've been doing Jujitsu,
for instance,
96 and that little dude from Brazil get
struggled the fuck out of me one day he
wants and that's a reality and I'm
almost a black belt.
I'm like high level and there's a lot of
people have choked out.
I can choke out some good people,
man,
and that guy could just tap me anytime
he wants.
So for me to be like almost a black
belt,
I might as well have never done Jujitsu.
I'll just be able to hold them off for a
little is gonna get me.
It's inevitable that that's the kind of
reality that exists for most people.
If you know Jujitsu for most people,
if you're in some sort of a street
altercation with someone and you get a
hold of them,
that's why you have to do so.
I have to do hang on because you know
what?
In class in class,
you're going 100 percent,
100 percent.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because you don't hit each other.
You're trying to choke and grappling and
grappling.
You're allowed to go 100 percent.
Doesn't mean you heard it.
Your,
your partners.
If you have a lock,
if you have a choke you,
you put it to a certain position and you
can just hold it and let it go,
but the point is it takes 100 percent of
your effort to get to that position and
that's exactly what's going to come up
in a fight and a fight.
It's going to be 100 percent effort
except you're used to doing 100 percent
effort three,
four nights a week,
three,
four nights a week.
I go in,
there's grown men and they're going to
try to kill me with their bare hands and
I'm going to try to kill them and then
we're going to slap hands and we hugged
and I said,
thanks brother,
and we move onto the next guy and you go
to the next one.
The next one,
he's tap hands you.
You go at your slap hands and said,
everybody does and any lockup and this
is the goal.
I'm going to try to get you to tap and
what you're saying when you tap is you
could have just killed me and then
you're gonna.
Try to do the same thing to me and if
you get me,
it's something I'm going to have to tap
and I'm not going to want to,
but I'm going to have to because very
important.
You don't want to die.
I thought opportunity right there,
just do it.
Hence Hensville.
Henzel gracie.
Benzos told me he was like,
come on out to the the place and I will
see,
will teach you Jujitsu.
Sure.
Why don't you do it.
I was like,
I know.
After I did the thing I said that was
really cool.
I felt really grounded when I got dunks.
I got beaten up a couple times and once
you get your ass beat,
but you know it's not.
There's no malice and you don't have to
go home to your little sister and she
looks at you and goes what happened?
And you're like,
like
it's a game.
And the game is using your body to
dominate another person's body with
technique and leverage.
I want to do it.
I want to do it because there I have so
many anxieties of just k.
it's the reason I want to get a fucking
massive dog.
It's the reason I want to fucking live
in Montana.
The reason I want to buy a shotgun,
every.
Everything.
I'm in Iowa,
it's like I just,
the reason I drink on planes,
it's,
I just,
I'm afraid like,
like you're afraid of a fight on a
plane.
Uh,
today.
Yeah.
Fucking guy.
How many,
by the way before we get started,
how many fucking fight stories I've ever
been started by this fucking thing?
Got that statement.
So fucking things that like what you got
in a fight to fucking guy like that
statement.
This fucking guy is probably number one.
All time.
Maybe the most appearances ever.
Fox Story.
Start this fucking guy.
This guy had his jumpsuit on.
He had two jackets on,
right?
So I'm watching him and then,
uh,
and he kept going to the bathroom.
He went to the bathroom like five times
while I went.
Once I kept watching him,
I was like,
what the fuck she doing in the bathroom?
So then I go in and after it goes in,
like the fifth time I go into and it
smells like Bengay,
like really fucking,
like really,
uh,
intense and I go and then I'd watch them
going like five more times.
And the one time he goes to the
bathroom,
I just walk up and I look at him and I
go,
what are you doing in the bathroom?
And the guy was like,
so you're on top of this guy's bathroom
shit.
Fuck you.
Where you like,
you think you're a cop of deodorant?
I don't.
You know what?
Here's the thing is I don't,
I don't know what he thought I was.
It wasn't deodorant.
I realized,
I think I realized what it was.
I think he was smoking something a
cigarette or those or the fake
cigarettes.
Electronic cigarettes cause it,
it smelled like,
like menthol in the back of exactly what
he's figured it out.
But when I said,
what are you doing in there?
He.
He was like,
oh no,
no,
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and went
okay.
But I didn't want.
I didn't know if he knew who I was,
but I was thinking if I could have
fucking fight this guy.
I was like,
how's this going down?
He might've thought that you were like,
oh,
martial arts.
Exactly what I was thinking.
I was like,
I don't want them to think anything
because I'm like the least suspecting
Air Marshall.
I just want him to know.
He told me.
He just gave us crazy eyes,
but he told me he wants to go and then I
realized he was smoking one of those
cigarettes in there probably it was
sketches of sketchy and he had like,
and here's what the way my crazy brain
thinks is he had those eyepatch patches
that you put on to sleep on a plane.
He had those like on his head,
like a pair of sunglasses like up here.
And I was like,
in my head I start going crazy and I'm
like,
he's a,
he's a fucking,
it's a plant.
He's got those because they told him and
terrorists class who make it look like
you're going to take a nap.
Like,
no,
this guy get the neck thing.
Oh,
I'm not going to blow up the plane.
So I just kept walking.
So you're really paranoid enough to
think that people are.
You're watching people's bathroom
behavior or something.
Have you ever thought it's just like
knocking yourself out and sleeping the
whole time.
Like that's what I wanted them to take
the laptop to watch a movie on your
account.
I definitely listened to the podcast
with you and a Ra.
Do you write on planes over?
Who are you?
That guy that stands up in the middle of
the island.
It looks at everybody acts like they're
getting something out of the front,
but then you're just checking everybody
out like,
no,
this today was a special occasion.
I know.
Normally freak out on planes.
Today was a special occasion because he
was going to the bathroom so much.
I went,
something's going on the fucking
bathroom.
Like I was just in my head.
I was like,
he's fucking dude.
There's something going on in the
bathroom and I'm the only person that
noticing.
He went to the.
When he was smoking a cigarette,
that's what he was doing.
He was smoking with a cigarette.
Can you can't ride on a plane?
You said?
No,
because I'm.
I'm a fucking mess.
I can't.
I want.
If you're listening to this and you can
fucking fix my flying,
you fucking do it.
I hate it.
I hate that.
I.
I can't listen to your podcast when you
do them on planes.
Really fucking give me a call.
I have another one I have to give you.
We did a 20 minute when me and Joey,
so there's a bonus bonus footage coming
ladies,
Joan,
but I can't.
I can't listen to them.
Like even just gives me anxiety.
You guys give me anxiety.
I don't know man.
I wish I could figure it out because
we're on a plane and you're going to put
all this sudden.
I'm telling them no,
no,
no.
If I want to play,
I'll never fucking listen to that one.
Want to noise reduction?
Apple plain bucket.
Eavesdropping on you and Tom Behind me.
Now he can't even listen to you on a
plane at home.
Like if I can't listen to it,
it gives me anxiety.
Wow.
When you're at home and you listen to
our podcast on the planet,
me,
anxiety me.
Am I the first guy to do podcasts?
And I'm playing.
That'd be awesome.
If I were you molested by a plane as a
young child.
No question.
My first lesson on my first plane trip
ever,
my dad is uh,
my,
my dad is a great man,
but he was not prepared to have you say
but soft things,
there's a list of them things that he,
uh,
that he did did as a parent that maybe I
wouldn't have done.
Like number one.
Like I remember when I was in first
grade,
I came home,
I was real problems.
Like Dad,
I'm the fastest kid in my class.
And he was like,
well,
you're not faster than me.
I was like,
Dad,
I'm pretty fucking fast.
I didn't say fuck,
but I was like,
I'm pretty fast.
And he was like,
really?
I was like,
yeah.
He goes,
let's go outside and race.
I said,
alright.
So we got outside,
I pull my knee socks up to my knees,
I get my little startup position that
almost went to the Olympics for track.
So we go and he's like on your mark,
get set,
go and I take off and I got the lead and
all of a sudden he blows by me and he's
running backwards.
He's like,
looks at me,
and he goes,
you'll never beat me at anything like
fucking first grade dad.
So when I took my,
I took a plane flight to Pennsylvania.
I remember,
uh,
the catcher for the,
for the Yankees,
uh,
was named,
um,
Shit.
It's escaping me,
but he died in a plane crash and I
remember saying to them,
a god,
I can't believe he.
He died in a plane crash.
And my dad goes,
yeah,
like,
what was it,
like a special plane flight?
I was a kid and taking my first plane
flight.
And he goes,
nope.
Sometimes planes go down.
And I was like,
like the one I go on.
And he goes,
yeah,
let's go.
They go down.
I was like,
Oh fuck.
And then I got on the plane and we
started taking off and I looked at my,
my dad was on the plane with me and my
mom and my sister were taken off.
I remember looking at my mom growing,
we're high enough right now,
I don't want to this.
And then he kept going and go,
stop going higher.
I start yelling.
How old were you?
Like fucking probably,
I want to say first grade,
first grade.
I had like a number of traumatic things.
I watched the dude light himself on
fire.
Yeah.
Fuck yes.
This kid John,
my end with the crazy part of this is my
uncle John was staying with us.
This kid John took me and corky gains
down the street.
It was like a redneck neighborhood.
And he goes,
uh,
you guys want to see a magic trick?
And we're like,
hey.
So he goes,
watch this.
So he dips a leaf in a,
in a,
uh,
in a butter jar,
butter tub of solution and then light
sitting in lights on fire.
The butter thing is obviously gasoline
going like,
wow,
that's amazing.
And he was,
I can do it again.
And so he did it again when I go and he
goes,
watch this.
And He poured a little bit and he lit it
and then the thing exploded and they
caught him on fire and he went like,
so I go taking off,
running to my house and I run into my
house screaming.
John's on fire.
My uncle John is sleeping on the couch
thinking he's on fire.
He's like pissed all over the couch,
but I saw that happen and it fucking
traumatized me.
What happened to the kid?
Quirky gains.
Oh,
quirky games rolled in dog shit like two
days later.
But John John,
he has pants.
My mom came down and my mom was like,
okay.
And he was like two days late.
It seems like crazy by the way.
Crazy right now is drunk.
No,
I'm not drunk.
I'm stone.
So many drinks.
Have you had your not stone sober?
You've had at least three beers.
Three Beers.
Joe,
do you think your stone sober?
I Bet I could do a field sobriety test.
Oh,
field sobriety.
You blow into a breathalyzer sign.
You're got to be locked up in the pokey
government.
Drunk is little bit different things.
Your government drunk.
Well,
let's.
Okay,
let's be fair right now.
We're all.
Jeremiah started drinking
at eight in the morning.
Cal earn or east coast?
Yeah.
We just won the moment.
You talked about that other dude,
Roland and dog shit.
Oh,
I thought you were asking what?
I'm going to coordinate gains.
So you saw a guy get lit on fire,
but nothing happened to him.
He's his pants.
His pants were on fire.
My mom,
that's it.
Are you kidding?
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
He was crying.
He was like,
I'm fine.
I'm upon nothing happened.
Don't tell my mom,
and then we just went home.
I never really hung out with that kid
ever again.
Wow.
I had a bunch
of traumatic shit.
Dude,
that ain't that big a deal,
but do you ever look at got lit on fire
and didn't even get hurt?
Fuck that guy guys to enroll you into a
judo class.
Now that I'm saying that I'm hearing
what I'm saying,
real hardships in childhood.
I saw my dad beat the fuck out of my
mother because she brought home
hamburger.
Are you serious?
Beat the fuck out of her.
Does that ever creep up in your foster
with an open hand?
Is Palm strike during the face?
Knocked her down.
Blood was coming out of her nose.
Screamed at,
or do you ever buy extra hamburger when
you're at the store?
Because it never stopped me from
enjoying the hamburgers.
I didn't allow it to.
I fought through it,
but that's nothing.
No,
I just had a Douche bag for a dad.
That's nothing.
You know,
there's people that have had real shit
happened to them.
A few real things happening.
That was nothing that got lit his pants
on fire a little posy.
My Shit's not real.
Now that you tell your story,
not the worst thing,
you just need more dramatic shift in
your life to think about.
So you wouldn't think about little shit.
No lifting.
Where a martial art
comes into place,
martial arts is so difficult and so hard
to do and you get nervous before every
class that it literally allows you to
look at other things as like their
minor.
Now you control these.
They're nothing.
They're not that big a deal.
Like a lot of people,
they break a bone or something like that
and it's like a really traumatic thing.
I haven't had like a gang of surgeries
do it.
I've had my nose fixed.
Both my knees fixed.
It's,
I've got a lot of shit done,
you know,
because things are always breaking
because you're getting them Yankton,
twisted and torked and but because you
get used to that,
you have a higher threshold for
uncomfort,
a higher threshold for,
for dealing with traumatic situation.
So you think ultimately if I started
getting into Jujitsu,
my fear of flying would disappear.
Yes,
because I would be feeling fear of
flying is your fear of everything
got connected and your fear of getting
mounted by another man.
We tried to choke you unconscious.
You're going to get past that.
As you get past that,
you'll get better at this whole flying
thing too.
That's what I believe.
It's a vehicle.
All martial arts are vehicles for your
human potential.
If you're not trying to be a
professional fighter,
they're trying to advance your human
potential.
I mean,
it's nice to have something to defend
yourself,
but just get rich and hires and
bodyguards if that's all you're looking
for,
you know,
but,
but per personal sovereignty for your
ability to be able to push your body to
a certain limit past that,
limit past the limit of what you thought
you were capable of,
that's all shit as you chug
the capable of that.
But if you ever look at the ratio of
people that died in plane accidents,
like car,
I don't have a fucking plan look ratio.
People that jump out of planes and die
is so uncomfortably I,
oh,
it's like 70 people a year.
There's only a few people like really
high.
And that was fucking panic.
Did you get to touch Rachel?
Rachel Ray,
right?
You get to touch her boobs on the way
down or anything.
I fucking freaked her out.
Imagine if you died and at the moment
you die.
The moment you both,
neither one of your parachute's hit the
ground or neither one of your
parachute's expand.
You both hit the ground screaming and as
on impact,
you immediately burst into another
dimension both completely naked,
floating in space and you're banging
Rachel Ray.
Yeah.
From behind that,
and then it's pure ecstasy.
It's like you're on ecstasy and Viagra
and and and almost pot to maybe even
mushrooms and your banging Rachel Ray
floating through space way.
He imagined that that's what death.
I would love to Bang Rachael Ray and
heaven and you're like,
and you're like,
God dammit.
I was scared of this.
I Love Rachel Ray.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
As you hit the ground is awesome.
Hot on the network.
That's a great rate statement.
When you said,
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
The fuck you did.
Russian Shaker network.
That's really sexy.
Which is that her name?
Her.
So sorry.
Hot.
So I walked up.
I,
we were in A.
I'm in the admiral's Club at,
at lax and I see her and she works for
food network and that's like how he
throws it in there or not.
I was at lax and I saw he was in the
admiral's club,
was the first class lounge I was flying
to do letterman and I saw her and now
we're both,
uh,
owned by scripts,
both our networks and so I said that I
see her but I've been drinking because
I'm about to fly and I just,
and our flights being delayed and
everyone's kind of sitting around and I
just looked at her and I go,
um,
we're owned by the same people.
She has no idea who the fuck I am.
I'm just saying we're owned by the same
people.
And she said,
excuse me.
I'm like,
I go like,
look at it.
I go on Bertha car,
no,
my birthday because I'm drunk and I'm
trying to relate to God.
Give me one of those.
She goes,
she goes,
I'm sorry.
And I go,
I go,
I'm on travel channel.
And she goes,
yeah,
and then.
And she,
yeah.
She's like,
are you?
Yeah,
I'm on travel channel.
Did you're on food network?
She goes,
what do you mean?
I go script scripts onto both of us.
She goes,
they don't own me,
and I was like,
no,
I meant like they own our networks and
we're on the.
I got,
my name's Bert.
I'm sorry I should have started this
differently.
She goes,
okay.
I just walked away and then our plane
got delayed and she drove home.
She drove home or playing out the lady
and she fucking drove home and uh,
and did not fly with me.
Wow.
That sucks.
Rachel Ray.
No know ray.
That was the original.
Raised my,
my girl.
We're going to Mexico in September.
If you were single,
Rachel Ray was finger,
would you try to fuck her?
She just nodded.
Rachel's to podcasts.
It's mostly primarily audio.
So that's a little extra treat for the
youth stream viewers.
Rachel is,
I will say this,
I will say this candidly,
she's married,
I'm married and I don't think there's
any sexual attraction that she has
towards me.
I'm,
I'll put that out there.
But man,
she's so sexy.
Like there's something very powerful
about her,
like she just handles herself with so
much,
like,
uh,
like initiative,
like the way she talks to you keep
popping those beers.
I've been while you're talking,
she's just,
she's awesome.
I have,
I have a great time with her.
Just makes me giggle and I fucking,
I love her.
I think she's hot.
She's hot.
Yeah.
I like that.
I would like rate and take her on a date
and never spending more than 40 bucks,
30 minutes fucking home run.
But she's achieved on those websites.
Are you serious?
Well,
you're on the website on another one,
but I came on in defending myself.
Wait,
what did they say about
you?
Oh,
it wasn't even me.
It was actually a friend of mine and it
was in Providence,
Rhode Island.
The,
the,
uh,
the cameramen were,
in town and this lady was really
retarded.
You're the guy from survivor.
I said,
no,
no.
I'm kind of,
I'm the guy from fear factor.
She goes,
oh,
okay.
Like,
disappointed.
Like I said,
something wrong or I corrected her,
upset at me that I corrected her and
like it was,
it was real weird and she came up to me
and she wanted to take a picture of the
membership.
Terrible stinky breath and I,
I agreed to take a picture of it.
Okay.
Thank you.
Nice to meet you.
And I said,
nice to meet you and that's it.
I left and then she wrote some whole
thing about me being a shitty temper and
that was really,
really rude.
Was Not even true.
I didn't even buy anything.
Came in.
They were already there.
I just came in and sat down and by the
way,
forever by the law,
be as generous as humanly possible.
Sometimes he tips.
I'm like,
Joe,
I,
you know,
understand that that's like your bills.
$20.
And he just tipped 100.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah.
But I
love it.
They feel good.
You know,
if someone's waiting on you and they get
that,
it's okay.
Wait tables where you start going out to
eat and go,
hey,
can I just wait my question?
Nick Lodge,
do you feel obliged?
Because,
uh,
because you would,
it's safe to say that all your friends,
uh,
don't make as much money as you.
Do you feel obliged that you have to
pick up the tip,
the tab every time?
I do have most of the time because the
way I say it is,
you know,
you can get into this who deserves it or
who's is it fair or what is money to you
could,
what's a dollar to you?
It was $5 to you,
you know,
when I was doing like fear factor,
especially money became very strange.
You know,
it becomes very strange when you have a
lot of it,
you know,
because then it's like,
why would you look if you pay $5 for
your meal,
then you have to think,
okay,
now I have 20 bucks left for the day.
If I'm paying $5 for a meal,
I don't think about it at all,
so let's just let me pay for it.
And then that way we don't have to think
about it.
And it's like the best allocation of
resources is how I looked at it.
It's the way I looked at as like I'll
pay for the tab every time simply
because it's easy for me to pay the tab.
Like it doesn't bother me at all.
Like if there's $100 missing from my
account or not,
it's not gonna hurt me.
It's not gonna change the way I feel.
Yeah.
But you know,
it sucks being friends with joe is that,
that gets to.
I mean the first in six months I knew
Joe,
I always felt like I was like,
no,
here's $20.
But then I gave up on that.
You just have to give up.
But then I'll find myself like feeling
bad about it,
like all the time.
So it'd be like at starbucks?
No,
no,
let me get this coffee.
No,
no,
no.
Seriously,
like it does drive me crazy because I
feel like,
uh,
I mean every time you go out to eat
especially were on the road,
it's just like you're always picking up
the bill.
It makes me almost not want to eat like
normal.
Like normally I would go to like a
restaurant,
be like,
all right,
I want the steak,
I want an appetizer,
but then when I'm like,
all right,
Joe's going to take that so silly.
It's so silly.
Whatever the fuck you want to eat,
I know,
but it still gets to you after.
He's a strange thing.
You know?
It's,
it's real strange when it becomes a like
a dividing thing between people and it
can really easily where people don't
feel like you're doing your part or
they're paying too much or I think
probably more fights between human
beings or financial more than anything
just excite you at all.
Excite me.
I like having it because it takes care
of problems.
The good thing about money is you can
need things or want things or you know,
want free time or money takes care.
All that shit.
If you.
If you have to fix your roof,
you got a hole in your roof.
Oh Shit.
Well when you have money,
it's just a matter of calling a roof guy
and having them come over and fix your
roof.
When you don't have money,
it becomes very stressful and it's a
fucking nightmare.
You think,
man,
I'm barely paying my rent.
How am I going to come up with the extra
two grand to fix this roof?
You know,
it becomes a real issue.
I like having it because of that,
but I'm not like,
not big on.
I'm not a flashy person and I'm not.
I like cars.
That's about it,
but I don't,
you know,
I'm not in a showy person.
Some people get really addicted to like
keeping up with the Joneses and that
becomes,
that becomes a real problem.
We're not,
but it's my,
my wife grew up in a trailer so we're
not the family.
Yeah.
But you could get that way when you get
really rich,
you know,
if this birth to conquer goes into
seasons 16 and you know,
the fucking travel channel has you and
they're big.
You're big giant fucking face on the
corner of like advertisements in a birth
to conquer entering the [inaudible] 16
season and then all of a sudden you're
living in Beverly Hills.
Oh,
I'm already fucking fucked up.
I'm fine.
Oh yeah.
In what way?
I'm fucked up in the whole,
like the prospect of fame,
I mean fame,
fame,
and I'm definitely not famous,
but like,
man,
I don't even want to say this because
it's like telling a secret about your
soul.
So,
okay,
just don't judge me.
Just hear me as a friend.
So I'm with my friends and uh,
this,
I feel dirty even saying this.
So I'm with my friends who are all,
have a ton of money.
Not that that matters,
but they're all in great shape.
They're all in the driving range rovers
and they own bars and respite and mad
came and gave.
My buddy has a best pickup line.
He goes up to this hot groaning goes,
who does everyone tell you you look
like?
And she's like,
Gwenyth paltrow.
And he was like,
I was gonna say missy Elliott.
And he walks away,
right?
Girls like,
fucking all over his shit.
Just insulting or right.
Anyway.
Anyway,
anyway,
Douche bag guy,
you guys said it's good.
And those lines like that,
that's a substitute for personnel.
So anyway,
so if I was a chicken,
hate your friend.
Okay.
So anyway,
a bunch of hot chicks were like rolling
up around us and,
and,
and they're,
and they're like,
and everyone's having a good time and in
my head because I'm this fucking father
of two who's just sitting there,
I hear my brain go,
um,
I hope someone recognizes us.
Like I hope I get recognized.
Like really?
Yeah,
because I might in a weird way,
my ego's fucked up because I know that
the girls for no,
so no one is banging you.
You're going home alone.
So like the only satisfaction you can
get out of this is one of the girls
going,
oh my God.
Exactly.
So I catch myself doing that and I go,
oh,
what the fuck is that?
Did you ask them to listen to the
podcast?
So I didn't understand a thing.
And then I'm sitting there and heard the
machine and I'm watching and I'm,
and everything's going down and I go,
this is,
this is unhealthy behavior right now.
What's going on is unhealthy.
And then as soon as I said,
this girl comes up and goes,
I got to get a picture with you.
And then my,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm done,
I don't need to fuck anyone tonight.
I'm done.
I got recognized like it's,
Oh,
it's,
yeah,
but that.
But that is,
it's,
it's addictive.
This shit,
the,
the idea of getting recognized or being
acknowledged for your work is so self
gratifying.
It's like,
it's almost like masturbating.
It's,
it feels good and it's shallow,
it's so fucking empty.
Shallow.
But in a weird way I can totally see how
people get fucked up on it.
Well,
shallow and maybe what you do is get
pete,
that's,
it's been a long time.
And uh,
it's been a normal thing for me to get
recognized for more than a decade.
So since fear factor was to get,
you know,
look,
the way I always say it is,
it's a bunch of people being nice to
you.
That's what it is.
People go,
does it ever get annoying?
Does it ever get tired?
It's just a bunch of people being nice
to you.
It's cool.
But I think it's very important to not
understand where it was,
you know,
the chain.
It's addictive.
It feels good.
It's very important to like put it all
into perspective,
you know,
and it's good to be recognized for your
stuff and it's good to do good stuff
that people like,
you know,
the beautiful thing about seeing,
you,
you run into someone out in public is
most of the time they're going to enjoy
what you've done.
You know,
most of the time if someone comes up to
you,
it's like they appreciate what you've
done.
And so you've given them something
already and you already,
you really,
even though you don't even know it,
you have a relationship with this
person.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
Okay.
No,
in all fairness.
Uh,
so,
but how did it feel when Bourdain,
who you,
who you're a fan of comes up to you and
is like,
I'd love to do your project,
one of sitting next to each other,
just completely randomly really at a,
at a restaurant in Vegas.
Oh,
seriously,
totally.
Seriously.
I literally,
he was as close as you are to me.
So I sat down and he reached up and he
said,
hey,
you know,
uh,
I,
I keep getting asked to things in life,
one to go fuck myself and to,
to do your podcast.
Are you serious?
Yeah,
that's what I said now.
Okay.
Be Honest.
So your heart flutter totally same shit.
I think that's the same shit ultimately.
So.
Oh God,
I'm obsessed with bordain.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
Yeah.
I enjoyed talking to him and he actually
came to my show at the,
uh,
the Mandalay Bay theater and I was
really any tweeted how funny it was.
He was like,
I mean,
I,
I love to this tweet.
It said saw Joe Rogan dive.
Very,
very funny.
You know,
I said we're going to have great things
to talk about in the podcast,
like interests and stuff.
That's what you said in the tweet.
And I remember reading that going,
wow,
I feel like I live in some sort of a
fucking fantasy land.
Some sort of a strange world that's not
real.
Fuck Dane,
man,
I enjoy that guy.
He does not.
He's not.
He would not tweet something he didn't
feel and,
and,
and he is a judge.
He's not a guy that if he didn't think
it was funny,
he would have never tweeted it.
And the fact that getting like three
various holy Fuck Vegas
man in Vegas during the night before the
UFC and it was me,
Joey Diaz.
Hey,
who else did you get to meet?
Joey does.
Doug Benson.
George sucralose was there and I just,
yeah,
Joey Diaz went out and crushed it.
We just let it fly.
Those,
those fucking Vegas shows are fun as
shit man.
When that place fills up and that,
that Mandalay Bay theaters like 1600
people,
it's huge.
It's fucking awesome to man.
And so bordain being the audience was
like,
it was really weird because I'm getting,
I'm,
I'm used to being around like,
you know,
Chuck Liddell and Rashad Evans and
fucking Leo Machida and Bj Penn and like
some of the best fighters in the world
where a lot of people would freak,
you know,
I see them like pj,
what's up?
You know,
it's like they're my friends,
you know?
To me it's like normal.
It's like meeting meeting you,
but you know,
for me to be around and do like Anthony
Bourdain,
it's like this is a different world.
He's a guy from the show
problems,
lb side first world problems.
First world problems is when he talks
about veganism,
vegans and vegetarian and he's like,
this is a first world option,
you know,
and that's what I've always felt when
people would go off about vegetables and
they're like,
you need to be a vegan animal.
Cruelty.
And I agree animal cruelty is fucked up,
but I don't agree.
You shouldn't kill animals.
You can go fuck yourself or what are
they going to live forever and cure
cancer if they stay alive.
This is ridiculous.
And guess what?
They'd kill you too.
There's a lot of shit that would kill
you and maybe maybe me live in,
you know,
I just,
I just don't know.
I don't agree with that.
So I don't hear very many people say
that.
So when bordain started saying that the
vegetarianism is a first world problem,
like,
yes,
thank you.
So the people in the world,
they need to kill things to sustain
themselves.
For Real.
It's like there's no options.
It's not like whether or not you choose
to not eat pig.
Like that's the only animal we have.
Stupid.
Eat The fucking peg is.
Are you going to get bored?
Eight on September 11th had really
American 11.
Are you fucking kidding me?
September 11th,
2011,
nine.
11 food.
Not 11 food hot dogs,
Bro.
Anything American?
Would it be awkward if I just showed up?
Now it's like you want to come in.
You ever hung out with them?
Never even met the guy.
Really great guy.
Great on his show.
Bring Rachel Ray.
You would be awesome on his show.
Where did you grow up?
Terrible.
Tampa.
Maybe you could take him tampon.
Show what's up to eat and Tampa clubs.
I'm not kidding,
man.
For Real.
If you have strip clubs that serve
Nachos,
Anthony Bordain will go there and eat
the Nachos.
Actually,
they're quite delightful and he would
sit there and eat Nachos at your strip
club.
Dude,
he eats.
Or street food.
Have you even watched the show?
Love Him.
I talked to the president of travel to
the other day.
My man needs treat fruit or renee called
me.
She goes,
you need to watch anthony show and just
watch it because she called him Tony.
She's like,
because what he's doing is perfect.
It is.
It is fucking perfect.
It is his voice.
It is his personality.
He doesn't do two or three takes of
anything.
It is fucking bear and he does it.
Personality driven.
It is personality driven.
When I said to him,
when I met him,
I said,
someone,
when you first started doing that show,
they must have just left you completely
alone.
He was totally.
He goes,
they just let you do whatever you do.
You like your show.
It's obvious that no one had a hand in
this like this is.
It's so clear that there haven't been
meddling executives to checking the way
he does his narratives.
No,
not 100 percent sense.
This podcast,
this podcast is so pure like that.
You listened to it and you go,
it's a Ah.
It's almost like,
like watch it,
like Doug Fan hope we called it the
quickening.
Like it just,
it just happens and you're like,
oh fuck.
Like this podcast that we've been on
today,
it's so bizarre because I've laughed.
Hardy Shit.
I've fought hardest shit I've felt I've
never enjoyed.
Out of the three ones I've done,
this is the one I've enjoyed the most.
Doing like this has been just fucking
because we're hammered.
Bready clink,
clink,
clink.
Rachel Ray Skater over.
Would you fuck her first?
When did you make her cook for you first
and then fucker her.
You fuck her then make or cook for you?
I'll cook for her.
Really?
Fuck Ya.
And then he'd be tired.
You went in,
put her leg and outstanding performance
together.
Here's a question for you.
Joe.
Do you get,
if you get stuff,
do you have to wait 30 minutes?
Like,
like pull style before you have sex?
Because I've noticed lately it depends
on whether it be generous.
Sometimes I just want it like I know
that the kids are awake and so I,
I can't,
I can get it off with a quickie quickie,
quickie boom and then I'll fall off the
bed and go into a coma.
When I get those freebies,
what I'm going to have to make her come.
That's awesome.
That's all the time.
So when you have kids,
but then sometimes you get a sneak one
in real quick and I've been told this
joke on stage.
You have to balance it out.
You have to make them come to.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
No,
I go,
I'll go.
I'll go down on her.
Yeah,
it's very important,
but I'm not willing to listen to them.
Oh,
go down on her.
The way you said that was like my uncle
used to take us fishing.
You have to go away to Vietnam.
You stepped back,
Shane Garner.
I was,
I was having sexual needs one extra
level.
You know my dad,
my dad gave me the speed and your dad
gave you speak.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hear me out.
My Dad,
my dad is on this.
He's,
he doesn't call it speed.
He calls it digests.
I tell you this,
Brian Daddy's medicine.
He calls it,
a doctor gave it to him for him to lose
weight and so my dad gave me like six of
them.
It's a weird.
He's going to eat to lose weight.
Yes.
They give you the speed and then it's
not like a ton of speed.
It's not like.
But it's,
it definitely curbs your appetite and
definitely are on speed.
But he gave me six.
He's like,
buddy,
I'm concerned about your weight.
Let's just jump.
Started a diet with these.
So he gave me six of them.
So I took one and then the second I took
it I was like,
this is fucking speed.
I called my dad.
I go,
dad,
it's speed.
You got to stop because it's speed.
And he's like,
buddy,
doctors aren't gonna prescribe the speed
I was,
it's like adderall.
It's like it's anything but A.
First of all I didn't need a fucking
thing.
I eat a grape and I appealed it.
And how many,
how long,
how many hours?
Like 12 hours.
Just didn't need it.
I was,
oh and I wrote like crazy.
Like I'm working on a book and I just
put up like,
oh,
you're so in the zone,
but it.
But you know,
it's,
I know it's unhealthy.
What is it like the come now?
What's the come down like a not there.
No,
no.
Come down.
So you took adderall.
It's basically adderall.
It's,
it's,
but it's an,
it's an APP.
It's specifically an appetite
suppressant.
What it is is.
Do you remember phen phen?
Yes.
It is the second of the fence.
I know a girl who lost a fuck load of
weight on phen phen.
Phen phen was a mood inhibitor and a
speed,
a mood inhibitor.
Serotonin.
It would induce your serotonin.
It was like one of those things.
First phen was like a zoloft and the
second one,
I fucking hate that.
I am talking right now and I'm really
not sure.
Joe.
I don't know.
I'm just kind of speculating.
This is my,
this is.
I'll just give you my research.
The first fan was like a mood inhibitor.
The second one was speed,
like agora fennel hall or something.
And what my dad is taking is the second
of the two friends.
And so he gave some to me and he's like,
buddy,
you just gotta jump started dying man.
It fucking works.
Really?
Yes.
And then you don't come down.
It's just.
I mean it's just,
you just get tired at the end of the
day.
On the pills on you.
Give me one.
I have one left on you right now.
Snorting.
Really?
Just it triple it up.
Yeah.
So we can.
So you can go fucking fight some guys
and Brian and I can drive back to la.
It might have a heart attack.
This stuff's rolling on speed.
But there's a doctor in Tampa that that
prescribes it to all my friends.
All my friends have lost a ton of
weight.
Of course they're all going to be dead
in a decade,
you know?
But it's like so low grade,
it doesn't feel like my dad's,
my dad's cardiologist knows he's on it
and my dad's cardiologist is better for
you to take that and lose the weight
because that's better for your body then
to the fat than to be fat.
So it get you down to my dad lost and my
dad.
Now this motherfucker is eating 500
calories a day.
Five hundred horrible.
Eddie's taken female urine.
What?
Like he's taken.
We all do that.
But what?
Ryan,
this is your best podcast I've ever been
on.
Brian,
you are murdering it today.
Much better when he's hammered.
No,
he's taken this female female get drunk
everyday.
This female urine drip under his tongue.
He's got a hold of me in a minute.
Once.
Just fucking come on.
Dog.
Female urine drip.
Call Your Dad.
This is ridiculous by the way.
His Dad,
uh,
we called his dad last time.
What was the for a soft softball.
Oh,
he broke his.
Yeah.
This is my dad's house.
This is crazy.
I'm broke.
Uh,
I was playing a baseball game when I got
hit their mouth and I got 26 teeth,
knocked out 2016.
And my dad,
my dad pulled me.
I have 32,
82.
Well you lost all your teeth.
All of these are from when you're
looking at from a softball,
baseball,
women's softball.
That's incredible.
How long did it take before they put the
teeth back?
Uh,
they will.
They started that that day,
like they started healing and putting in
caps and crowns and posts and everything
that day.
But um,
but I,
this is totally true.
Totally fake teeth.
One hundred percent fake.
No.
Yeah,
like everything you're seeing all the
way to the gold ones.
Yeah.
Wow.
So crazy.
Listen to this.
So my dad,
I,
this happened,
my dad was my coach and I was like,
oh,
my teeth run home plate.
I was catching my teeth won't fucking
plate.
And I was like,
oh.
And he was like,
buddy,
take off the couches,
catcher gear,
go to shortstop.
And I was like,
what?
He's like,
you gotta finish eating a real,
lose a game.
I was like,
the fuck you talking about.
And he was like,
come on,
let's go man up over and shortstop.
He made all his teeth,
got knocked out.
I was a child.
My Dad is a really great guy.
I'm making him sound horrible.
But,
but he said,
well,
just douchey.
No,
he's just,
he's he,
let's call them.
Find out about the speed or the women's
urine friend.
The name of it to is.
Does your dad feel bad about doing that
to you as a child?
You know,
he was just a different guy.
It was a different time.
That's a different time.
Like he was running marathons.
He was.
Sounds like you could.
Oh No,
I'm sorry.
I doubt my house,
my house,
my old house.
I got home.
Sorry.
I meant to my mom and dad.
God,
that fucking scared me.
I was just like,
oh my parents are like scares you bro.
Yeah.
Why is this scared when we start smoking
some weed?
No,
when he did,
when he did the,
uh,
the,
the noise of me hitting the ground and
going into the next dimension.
You saw me jump.
Alright,
here we go.
It's a,
it's a pregnant female urine he puts
under his tongue.
Okay,
well who doesn't do that?
We [inaudible] you've reached the
crushers.
You know,
they used to use rabbits.
Lisa inject women's urine into rabbits
to find out if the woman was pregnant
and it's the rabbit died.
That means that the woman was pregnant.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
It's called the rabbit.
You didn't know that.
The rabbit
test.
I've got good news and I've got bad
news.
Your rabbit's going to die.
It's my parents,
my parents.
Okay,
hold on.
I'm pretty sure they call you back.
Hello?
Albert,
what are you
Ahmed?
Uh,
my friend's house.
We're a Joe Rogan's house.
Mom,
are you familiar with Joe Rogan's work,
Khalid Jew boy.
Joe Rogan.
You are?
No,
she's not.
She's not familiar with your birth mom.
What is,
what does dad put under his tongue?
How forcible,
how much weight is dead?
Last,
uh,
23 pounds.
And what does he put under his tongue?
I'm going to the refrigerator to find
it.
And I want you to know I've put your
life on hold to talk to you.
Okay,
great.
It is called ready Google this.
It's female.
It's pregnant.
Women's urine,
right?
Mom.
Oh,
God knows whether that's what it is.
I'll text you the technical date.
Okay.
You can't just say it.
I'm A.
I'm a phonics teacher,
but flora run the chorionic.
Chorionic.
Not that one.
No,
I don't.
To go
a few minutes,
Lori.
I got dod,
Doj.
Japan is done to check the hormone hcg
in blood or urine
yesterday.
They tti?
Yes.
Some hcg tests measure the exact amount
and some just check to see if the
hormone is present.
HCG is made by the placenta during
pregnancy.
The HCD
fucking told you it can be used to see
if a woman is pregnant or as a part of a
screening test,
but he's lost.
He's lost a lot of weight though,
right?
It has something to do with pregnancy
because he's put magnet urines 500
calories a day.
Wow.
That doesn't sound like enough,
but he really doesn't eat 500 calories a
day because he told Dave that he cheats
and space under a thousand and that's
why he's last week.
Thousand.
Sounds reasonable.
500.
Sounds crazy,
right?
Mom,
I'm going to let you go.
I love you.
Love you too sweetie.
Bye.
5,000
calories is too little too though.
I mean like,
like if you're only doing 500 calories,
what is he eating?
His chicken.
I did it one day with him when I was.
It's a half a chicken
breast and a handful of Broccoli and
that's one meal and the next one is
another handful of Broccoli and another
half a chicken breast and you're allowed
a bread stick that's so extreme.
The urine stuff gets you.
It's like a testosterone thing.
It starts sort of jasmine,
you and he gets like B,
12 shots and he goes to this doctor
all the time and yeah.
Pissed or whatever.
I've never worked for the news.
Yeah.
You to be more specific.
They invaded Sam B.
Twelve shots.
The fucking pregnant.
Piss on.
You know,
he's on speed.
Was he got sentenced to use this?
She say placenta.
Yeah.
Have something to do with placenta.
I get my Puente students at GSA in
Glendale.
It's cheaper in Glendale.
Yeah,
Glendale.
Really?
I don't know.
There's just more in Glendale.
Glendale.
Yeah.
I just got your uh,
laptop.
What?
I just understood your laptop.
Oh,
it's snow white.
Still waiting in the apple laptop broke
just now.
The crusher.
Quite hammered.
I'm not.
I'm first of all,
I'm the suburbs.
One in the whole room.
That's impossible.
No 100 percent.
Impossible or possible sound possible?
It's totally possible.
The person that says that the service
person in the room is rarely sobers
person in the room.
Let's do a protest.
All right.
Let's.
Do you want to do a google it?
Sober tests if you had a Dui?
Never will.
Listen,
I could do those things when I'm drunk.
Uh,
would you eat Rachel Ray's ass?
No.
Why are we doing Rachel Ray?
I would say
it's over time.
It's totally going to lose Brian.
So Brian is sober.
He's been cleared.
Please leave the room.
You are cleared me to left.
This is like fucking heads up.
Poker.
I'm all in.
I'm all in with my liver.
You're all in and you're stuttering.
Okay.
Congratulations.
By the way,
on the hurricane this weekend,
you will not be get having a show with
Carlson.
Celia Mysia.
Joe,
you've been getting this wrong so many
years.
It's been a whole lot of weight lately,
so maybe he needs to be called them Sia.
Yeah.
Maybe he's turned over a new leaf.
Maybe or all.
He's probably into Jujitsu.
Married woman's hearing
isn't a woman's urine.
HCG,
the Glendale.
And you've got to get the good pregnant
woman's during the Mexican shit.
That's the strong stuff.
Just a touch of Jalapeno in it.
Squirted into your mouth.
You just.
The weight just sheds.
Appeals.
Yeah.
My favorite podcast ever.
I think it's my favorite.
I just want to do it sober one again.
All right,
now listen,
we can.
You just drank.
The last one we did drunk was Doug
Stanhope.
That was like a great fucking.
Why don't you come back?
We needed that.
We love to man before he shoots himself.
Oh,
that's just the show.
Doug's good.
No,
it's sad watching that.
Although if he kills himself,
you know,
hunter s Thompson style,
when he decides that his body's falling
apart,
I wouldn't be surprised.
But I think that's probably a really
logical way to do it.
Have you heard his podcast with Tom
Rhodes?
Here's a hope.
He did a podcast with Tom Rhodes.
Really?
Uh,
it's,
I,
I just stumbled on it because I was
going through this,
uh,
Tom Rhodes phase and I,
and I found it.
He,
they date it is the most beautiful
ending of a podcast I've ever heard.
They talk about taking mushrooms
together and then thinking the earth
who's going to spend them off and Tom
Rhodes starts going,
yeah,
and this song was playing in the
background and Doug was like,
it was,
and then I decided I didn't have the
wherewithal to to get up and use the
restrooms,
urinated in my pants and Bingo.
Took my pants and change me and Tom
Rhodes,
he goes,
who was one of those beautiful moments?
And then they start singing together
together.
They start singing the song and it picks
up in the background and it's the most
awesome moment I've ever heard and I was
like,
it's so beautiful.
If you just go.
If you googled the podcast and you just
hear,
don't listen to the whole thing because
Tom Roses sometimes Tom Rhodes sometime
mean I liked tom rose,
but like he tells doug,
he goes,
Doug,
what's going on with the stand up?
And Doug's has been drinking again and
he's on an ambient in this podcast.
And so.
And he,
he's been drinking a lot.
So he says at the beginning,
don't miss anything.
I'm saying because I don't know what I'm
fucking saying tonight.
And then Doug says he was dealt with
standup.
Doug goes,
I'm fucking done.
I hate it.
I've done everything I'm doing.
I'm just rewriting the same jokes.
I'm a shill.
If I could just quit this and fucking
never come back,
I'd do it tomorrow.
And then silent Tom goes,
so what do you like about my standup?
It was a fake question.
It's clear that there,
but just so fucking hammered in this
podcast and if you add that,
that's how we should end today.
We should all sing a song together about
my standup.
That's the name of the song.
Are you guys in key?
I did.
Um,
I did mushrooms with Doug the day the
war broke out the very day of we did,
you know,
it was breaking out.
We knew it was broken out,
so we decided to go out to the desert to
do drugs.
We went to a yawn,
Irvin's house.
My man who was on this podcast,
we've ever done that.
Dan's a good guy.
Didn't work out,
but listen to thinking it was Aubrey
Plaza.
I told Brian that,
who's the girl from 30 rock?
Mark Marin
had interviewed.
I'll reply to you interviewed the Aubrey
Marcus.
I just saw Aubrey and read the
description on Marin's and I go to 30
rock chick.
I want to hear how I want to hear how
joe deals with it before I go to Marin.
It's only here the jove version first
because that'll be a little different.
It's going to be all gossip.
Celebrity gossip.
Marin.
I want to hear how joe deals with it and
I hear it and it's operating.
That's a dude.
I go,
oh,
that must be the dude from from parks
and recreation.
And he's like,
yeah,
I changed my name.
I did all this Iowaska and I'm like,
fuck,
there's couple of balls.
He's on NBC talking about going to
Iowasca.
It's fucking driven as balls.
NBC.
He's on parks and recreation.
Oh,
that's funny.
You thought it was the whole podcast.
I'm like,
man,
this guy is a deep motherfucker and then
I go to Marin's and it's a chick.
I go,
oh,
fucking different offerings.
But what you're saying about mushrooms
and you and hope that we did it,
data war broke out.
We knew that the war with the United
States was going to war on this
particular day.
So we drove out to the desert with this
dude lived.
We got blitzkrieg on machines.
We took a couple different kinds.
We started out with the Amanita
[inaudible] area and then we moved our
way into psilocybe cubensis.
Wait,
there's different mushrooms.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
The ammunition and Endeca.
Endeca.
What's,
what's the ones that grow on a cow?
Shit.
Those are [inaudible] cubensis
mushrooms.
But there's different kinds of cubensis
There's a bunch of different species of
psychedelic mushrooms,
including some that have no history or
known history of human use,
their psychedelic chemicals that people
that we don't even believe that people
discovered like a Hawaiian baby.
Woodrow.
Um,
there's a,
I believe there's no evidence of human
use of that until I really recently.
And it contains the same chemical
compounds as Lsd,
a believer.
I'm,
yeah.
I'm might be a little off on that.
Lysergic acid.
I know it's something to do with that
and there,
but either way it's a very strong
psychedelic compound,
but there's almost no history of human
use,
so it was like one of those weird things
where people might have missed that one,
you know?
No,
I can't do psychedelics anymore.
No.
Why do you say that?
Because I know my brain the last time I
keep saying that,
but let me tell you something that
anybody tells me.
I know my brain is the number one
candidate for a psychedelic experience
because you say that you can't do
psychedelics,
but you know your brain.
What I.
What I hear is my ego has tricked me
into this position who are have stood my
ground and I'm terrified of anything
really truly frightening and
revolutionary,
so I'm going to operate by clearly
defined,
predetermined pattern of behavior that I
find acceptable and I'm going to stick
to that whenever anybody brings it up
and then everybody brings it up.
I'm going to say,
well,
I know my brain,
and the last time you did it,
you did it before a show.
You can't.
You can't do shrooms in the show and
didn't get work on a show,
and I was watching shadow people in the
crowds and he's scared of shadow people.
Every time we shrooms,
he.
I can't.
I know.
I mean I could,
I could,
I could theoretically eat mushrooms if
it was the right moment.
The right time.
Could 100 percent.
No,
but it would definitely need to be
during the day,
like couldn't do it at night.
I'd never been able to do it at night.
Heightened states of tension that are
appropriate.
You know,
it's understandable if you're at war,
if you're,
you know,
you're hunting,
gathering your fucking chasing a deer,
but heightened stakes for no reason
which you seem to acquire.
Yeah.
I don't know how to deal with them.
To me,
you look at the natural balance of a
human being.
Genetically we have the same DNA as
fucking people that live 10,000
years ago that were throwing pointed
sticks at running animals.
We have the same Goddamn DNA yet we have
these bodies that we don't exercise.
We don't push them,
we don't make them do things and I think
there's a great deal of,
of,
of human tension and stress and and and
imbalanced that comes from not taking
care of your body,
that your body misfires and sends
chemical signals that don't make sense
and it's confused and doesn't know how
to handle itself and it's insecure and
it's fucked up and it's weird because
you don't understand it.
Exactly.
And that makes your body.
Did it fucks with you,
it deceives you,
it throws you bad signal.
I'm afraid I'm afraid because when like
my brain already fires by itself,
like it just starts saying things and I,
and I think we're comedy.
My comedy comes from at least and I'm
afraid when like now I get to a point,
this is where I was last time is we took
some mushrooms and I realized that the
second I took them that I'm a father and
I was like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I can't get off the grid the way I did
in college.
I can't just hop off the grid,
disappeared for six hours,
have a fun adventure down the itch and
Tuck me like I'm a father who's fucking
with not only my livelihood but the
livelihood of my children,
like if I do pull a trigger in my head
and I can't come back if something fucks
up in my head,
I have now ruined life for too long and
that,
that thought is what fucked me up for
the night.
And then one of my buddies like,
fucking just get as drunk as you
possibly can.
I was like,
alright,
that's what we'll do.
So.
But that.
And it was a fun night.
I had a great night after that when I
was like,
fuck it,
I'll just keep drinking.
That's my biggest.
That's my,
that's where my head.
It lives when it comes to psychedelics,
will you talk to the wrong dude?
See if you were talking to me.
Oh,
I see.
Okay.
You're the kind of person that I would
be.
I would be fine.
Um,
I would,
if I was going to do mushrooms again,
I would definitely want you to do it
with you.
Even if you're not going to be okay,
it's eventually going to be okay.
I wouldn't remember that.
Remember,
I wouldn't even know what.
You're not going to be.
Okay.
You're eventually going to be okay
because this is temporary.
Even if you're not going to be okay,
you're going to be okay.
I just want to get your deprivation
tank.
You can do it.
Why wouldn't you do drugs with me?
Because I think you would freak me the
fuck out.
Well,
just it'd be way too intense and you
would scare the fuck out of me.
Like it'd be too intense for me.
Joey Diaz was scared.
The fuck could not do mushrooms to Joe
and say,
Oh,
I cannot deal with Joey.
Just all of a sudden snapping and
yelling me for no reason.
Which by the way,
red already got mad at Brian when he was
on acid.
Serious?
Yeah.
Uh,
oh yeah.
I said at the UFC,
but he got he.
Joe,
you know,
I'm starting to think that I just don't
mix well at Jewish people.
Oh a great way to end or Hollywood.
Andy Dick on the line now.
Just kidding.
No,
I mean he's always mad at me,
I always rubbed me the wrong way and
it's,
it's like,
because it already is a certain people
that I always get along with and then
there's people like Laurie who is
already is already like,
and I will,
you know,
are a million ways better than I do,
but I will definitely say that Ari is a
different type of human being.
He told me the other day,
Tom Scott calls me.
He goes,
someone's telling that Tracy Morgan
story that's working with already this
weekend.
I said,
shut up.
I go,
what had already said already say to
him.
He goes,
oh,
nothing.
I go,
wait.
So ours is working with a guy that was
telling the Tracy Morgan story and he's
saying some other celebrities tell him
this,
but it really happened to me.
This art is working with the guy for
fucking six shows.
Who is this guy?
It's a black comic and he told the whole
weekend,
I don't know the name because fucking he
doesn't know his name.
He worked with already the whole weekend
and told this story on stage.
Fucking sad.
He doesn't remember.
He goes,
I forget,
you know,
I was trying to work some fuzzy.
I was pretty high.
They had good.
We'd like,
it was just typical bar that I go,
I go,
how do you not like,
I love like if that,
if someone was telling a story of or
Joe's or yours,
the onstage,
I would be texting you tomorrow.
But rhs was like,
well that's fucked up.
Okay.
Right.
People don't drink,
don't know how good food is because
right now I've had a couple of periods
right now.
I've had a couple of beers and I'm
looking at the clock and I know in 10
minutes [inaudible] in culver city
closes.
We can't really make it unless we leave
right now.
Now the only way to get a real sausage
sub sausage with fucking sausage.
Tomato sauce.
Sausage and peppers in culver city.
Cavaradossi?
No,
not culver city.
Um,
did I say culver city?
He did,
yeah,
he did.
I guess he was drunk.
What's his name?
Is M A,
a c might be chatsworth.
No.
Huh?
Canoga Park.
That's what it is
though.
Unfortunately.
I'm fuck up.
That's blues man.
Dudes,
you don't know.
That's one of the things I love about
bordain that eats treat food.
He'd fucking fried sausage peppers on
the side of the highway
and he doesn't.
I get terrified sometimes that I go,
Oh man,
I don't like you ever seen those.
It's always fucking terrified about
something.
You get terrified about everything.
I wanted to stop.
I want it.
You wanted to start?
I wanted to stop,
but I just like worried though that if
it stops the you're not going to be fun
anymore.
They wanted to put me on pills.
They said I had social anxiety disorder.
I was like,
I don't fucking,
I don't like that shit.
And they were like,
well we want to get you on a mood
stabilizer.
Like one of those mood stable as a cola
broke pill.
Yeah,
take away what makes you interesting?
Yeah.
It's the thing that like my brain works
a certain way.
I'm cool with that.
My Wife's school that my kids are cool
with it.
My friend circle that,
if you don't know me,
it may be weird,
but I get it and I,
I fuck around and I,
you know,
I will test the boundaries of my mind,
but I definitely wouldn't.
I don't know.
It's good.
Your brain is
good.
This is different.
You know,
this,
I believe that there's a bunch different
components and ingredients that all put
together to make everything including
society and human beings and people have
to be different.
There has to be different kinds of
people and you know,
and too much society wants to take
people that really don't have problems.
They're just.
I mean everybody has problems but
they're just fucking different and
society wants to curve their edges and,
and,
and straighten their curves and make
them,
you know,
something that fits.
Yeah.
No,
and that's,
that's unfortunate man,
because the most brilliant people,
the most fun people in my life,
the Doug stand hopes and the Joey Diaz
is and the burke crushers and you know,
all these people.
This life is richer because I know
people like that.
I liked the spontaneity.
All I keep thinking the whole time,
let's drink some pis like that's all
that because of the.
Because we talked about.
I wonder how bad it is.
Like I'm just in the right mood.
Bad.
Did you get your money?
No,
I don't want to drink your pitch.
Why not?
And you want me to go get some glasses?
Come on and bring it forward.
Drink.
Yeah,
we'll just trying to close.
Brian.
Scared.
There's no reason
I'm taking a little trip to the man.
You just got to demand table.
We're talking about drinking.
Pulled his dick inside.
Like a little turtle.
I don't trust my own P and L.
No.
Just be beer.
He got scared.
Yeah.
It would just be straight beer.
You just be drinking warm curoil.
That's what I'm drinking right now.
I might as well just as far tonight.
Each other's faces,
but that's better brand.
I'm gonna.
Take you to a doctor.
Dr.
Burt's.
Okay.
But I think you fucked up.
You might need those pills that he ran a
weekend to do Jujitsu class and it takes
them.
No,
Brian.
Brian is down for pregnant woman
Jujitsu.
He's only compete with pregnant women
because they don't really try that hard
go.
Like when there's a baby here,
it's like,
okay,
so you're tapping.
Tapping right to have a baby in here.
Okay.
If you only had to fight a woman who was
like nine months pregnant,
pregnancy yoga,
it was pregnancy.
Folks.
Let's fucking shows over O v e R,
please follow my man burt on twitter.
It's burt b.
e are not like Ernie and Bert,
but b,
e r t e k r e I s c h e r,
one of the funniest human beings.
I know.
Please follow him on twitter.
Let me put on Adam Carolla's reading
glasses so I can read my schedule.
See every please come,
come,
come one.
Come all.
September 16th,
New Orleans,
the House of Blues.
I'm a believer.
I'm doing that with Duncan Trussell,
Duncan trussell and Duncan is bringing
back little Hobo.
We had a conversation about it right
away.
You're going to buy someone stole a
little Hobo.
We're going to buy a new little Hobo and
we're gonna.
Conduct a seance live on the podcast to
bring the spirit of the original little
Hobo into the new little Hobo,
blah.
That's awesome.
Nine slash 23.
DENVER,
Colorado.
The paramount theater almost sold out.
Bitches hop on that
shit.
That is the day before the UFC.
September 24th,
which is John Jones versus quinten
rampage Jackson Hole.
So that's September 23rd.
DENVER,
Colorado.
Paramount theater.
Holla at your boy.
Thank you very much for the flashlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan.net
and click on the link for the
flashlight,
you can enter in the codename Brogan and
get 15 percent of his eyes are worse
than me.
I was lying.
It was shit.
After a while it gets annoying.
Oh,
give to my documentary.
If you can find the document.
Hold on.
I gotta say these people are entering
the code name,
Rogan and get 15 percent off number one
second start for men.
Then you can make money as your
documentary.
If you go to twitter.com
and [inaudible] dot com.
There's a link there.
I'm sure.
Bert,
Bert Dot com.
Okay.
And this is a documentary where a,
obviously after listening this podcast,
he realized that he needs to be
followed,
so needs to fall part crusher.
It's just snow.
No two buts about it.
Thank you to a opie and Anthony who
remained my friends and some of the
coolest fucking people on radio.
I did live at the compound this,
uh,
the other night,
I was at home on a Saturday night or
whatever the fuck it was and anthony was
doing his show and it was like 2:00
in the morning and in New York.
And so I called in and I was on their
show.
I was on his show for like a half an
hour.
Seriously?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He does a show in his basement.
That's how cool he is.
He,
even though he's on Opie and Anthony,
he does his own show from his fucking
house and he's the inspiration for why
Brian and I chose to do this and why we
started out doing it on ustream and
doing it on a webcast brass craft.
Anyway,
it was really cool to do that.
Um,
thank you to everybody made the podcast
number one out of all podcasts on itunes
this week that is seeing that the most
downloaded podcast,
number one out of all the podcasts on
itunes was crazy,
seeing number one and number four was
really crazy.
I can.
So we had number one and number four,
the top 10 most downloaded podcast that,
that was a trip.
I'm glad you guys are enjoying the fuck
out of it.
We,
we love doing it.
And the reason why we love doing it is
because you guys enjoy it.
If you guys weren't listening it would
be absolutely useless.
And if we were just by ourselves,
we would run out of shit to talk about.
So thank you very much for Mr Kreischer,
one of the funniest,
most interesting people I know and it's
one of the coolest things about having
this podcast is to be able to bring all
of us together like this.
It's an amazing thing.
How much boy bitches.
All right,
put a little fucked up.
This is an interesting podcast,
but it's over now.
And we'll see you on Wednesday with God
knows who Kevin Smith.
Uh,
August 30th and Anthony Bordain
September.